[Musique]
Jean-Philippe Tangi, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? tout
simplement Jean-Philippe Tangli 39 ans
né à Boulog surmer député de la Somme
député Picard dans le groupe
Rassemblement national et donc donc je
suis le président délégué
aujourd'hui on va parler guerre
économique
ingérence premier ministre dissolution
et tout un tas de conneries de finances
et gens passaient des meilleurs. Avant
de commencer les hostilités si on peut
appeler ça des hostilités et ça fait
quoi de payer ses études en étant
serveur ? Ben écoutez, à postériori euh
ça fait une forme de fierté.
C'est-à-dire que sur le moment, comme
beaucoup de Français qui n'ont pas le
choix, on se dit "J'aimerais bien être
comme les petits copains ou les petites
copines qui ont plus de liberté, qui
peuvent s'amuser et puis finalement on
se dit que que ses parents
volontairement ou involontairement nous
ont donné une bonne idée et donc
finalement d'avoir peut-être plus de
difficulté à valider ses études parce
que c'était plus difficile euh
finalement parce que bah vous avez des
doubles journées hein tout simplement
hein double journée car même vous
racontez une anecdote quand j'ai passé
le le jury de les secces, une école de
commerce, vous avez un oral, vous
racontez un peu votre vie. Et quand j'ai
dit au juris de l'essour racontent une
vie et s'inventent une vie, donc quand
j'ai raconté la mienne et que j'ai dit
j'étais serveur et que le soir même
d'ailleurs après ce jury, je retournais
servir en créperie, ils n'ont pas cru.
Et en fait le lendemain, j'ai reçu la
visite de la représentante des étudiants
qui sientit à ce jury pour vérifier si
j'étais bien serveur et si c'était bien
vrai. Et pour la petite anecdote, j'ai
eu une mauvaise note parce qu'il ne
m'ont pas cru et qu'il était trop tard
pour changer la note. Ça ne m'a pas
empêché de rentrer. Mais d'ailleurs
cette anecdote qui bon qui est plutôt
rigolote en fait à postériori en fait
c'est un des débuts de prise de
conscience. C'est-à-dire, c'est c'est
intéressant votre question première
comme ça parce que c'est là aussi où
j'ai réalisé moi venant d'une famille de
la classe moyenne moyenne ayant cru avec
toute la sincérité et toute la
spontanéité dans la méritocratie
française gravillant les petits échelons
en pensant que tout ce système
fonctionnait bien et ben paradoxalement
au moment même où je rentrais dans la
dernière étape on va dire des études
républicaines je me suis pris le mur
d'une autre réalité dans la dans la
tronche à savoir des gens qui étaient
tellement tellement déconnecté qu'il
n'arrivait même pas à imaginer alors que
c'est la norme chez les étudiants qu'on
pouvait à la fois postuler à une grande
école, avoir atteint enfin avoir le
niveau enfin avoir eu les notes qui
permettaient d'arriver à l'oral et
d'être serveur en même temps. Ça leur
paraissait inimaginable. Et en fait, de
cette petite anecdote,
on peut déduire beaucoup de malaise et
de mal-être dans notre pays. Et des gens
en fait, on entend souvent, il y a des
gens qui sont dans la réalité, il y a
des gens qui sont pas en fait. qu'il y a
juste des réalités majoritaires et des
réalités minoritaires ultra minoritaires
et la réalité des des de la majorité des
gens de l'essèc ou de la chaussée ou
c'est pas qu'ils sont pas dans la
réalité, ils sont dans la leur et leur
défaut en tant qu'élite dirigeante ou
aspirant à diriger, c'est pas qu'il
vivent dans une autre réalité. Ils n'ont
pas choisi cette réalité comme quelqu'un
qui est né dans une famille modeste ne
l'a pas choisi. Mais il devrai par les
responsabilités qu'ils ont, par les
privilèges qu'ils ont eu, être ouverts à
d'autres réalités, ils ne le sont pas.
Ils sont obtus, fermés à d'autres
réalités qui viennent les déranger. Donc
c'est c'est intéressant votre question
parce que cette petite anecdote en fait
beaucoup de la de la société des élites
françaises qui sont très différentes
d'autres élites occidentales. He il y a
en France espèce de paradoxe,
c'est-à-dire à la fois des élites
qui pensent vivre dans une méritocratie
et en fait contrairement à d'autres
peut-être les Britanniques ont
conscience qu'il y a une vraie
aristocratie qui il y a vraiment des
écoles alors il dit public school mais
c'est pas des écoles publiques.
justement des écoles privées. Et en
fait, les Britanniques par exemple qui
sont quand même des très proches cousins
ont paradoxalement beaucoup plus
conscience de leur société de privilège
et leur société de classe et en tire un
respect du peuple beaucoup plus fort.
Alors que les élites françaises qui sont
persuadées de vivre dans une dans une
méritocratie, bah ce qu'il y a une
soisant une méritocratie, sont très
arrogants envers le peuple qui devrait
servir. On l'a vu avec le Brexit, hein,
les élites britanniques ont appliqué en
tout cas globalement appliqué la
décision populaire, le vote du Brexit.
Alors que les élites françaises pour un
vote assez semblable, celui de la
Constitution, contre la Constitution en
2005, ne l'ont pas respecté.
J'ai alors je voulais vous poser la
question sur est-ce qu'il faut imposer
les pourboirs ? Mais mais on va passer
il
faut pas imposer les pourboir. Mais ça
aussi c'est important.
On va on va on va passer on va passer
directement à une question. Je vais
rebondir sur ce que vous venez de dire.
cette consanguinité des élites, ces
œillères qui se mettent, est-ce que
c'est pour ça qu'on n' pas vu venir la
crise financière, les révolutions
arabes, la guerre parce que il y a une
consanguinité
de gens qui ne pensent que dans une
seule boîte et qui n'ont pas les
capacités de modéliser une réalité
différente et de faire remonter de
l'information à nos dirigeants
de de première main sans sans faire
plaisir à son N + 1, N + 2 parce parce
qu'ils veulent pas entendre ça.
Oui, tout à fait. Alors bon, pour la
crise financière, il y a aussi beaucoup
de conflits d'intérêt, de conflit de
classe, hein. C'estàd que vous avez des
gens qui s'enrichissent en sachant
pleinement qui vivent dans un monde
parallèle et que une forme de marché ou
un accident de marché, on pourrait y
reparler pour la crise de 2008, viendra
les rattraper. Mais bon, ça ils s'en
foutent. Mais en fait à la limite, si
les élites françaises à la limite ne
comprenaient pas, vous avez parlé des
révolutions arabes, bon euh moi-même de
mon point de vue j'avais pas forcément
conscience que Ben Ali en Tunisie était
aussi fragilisé euh ou ne tenait pas
autant son appareil d'état. Bon bref,
mais
vous connaissez le proverbe quand il n'y
a plus de foin dans les rateliers, les
chevaux se battent. Si vous aviez en si
vous aviez fait une veille sur
l'énergie, la calorie que ce soit
alimentaire ou énergétique, vous auriez
peut-être pressenti des tensions sur
l'augmentation du coup des matières
premières alimentaires qui aurait
peut-être un petit peu stimulé
les révoltes.
Vous avez sans doute raison mais en tout
cas moi j'avais pas cette perception, je
vais pas m'inventer une vie après. Mais
ce qui est plus inquiétant, c'est qu'ils
sont aveugles sur leur propre peuple.
Parce que par exemple, moi je vous dis,
j'avais pas du tout senti venir
forcément le les révoltes arabes, mais
par exemple le phénomène des gilets
jaunes, pas le phénomène lui-même, mais
le fait qu'à partir d'un moment, comment
dire, le prix du carburant et en fait on
a parlé du carburant mais du gaz, du
fioule, même le prix du bois pour le
chauffage devenait comment dire
complètement insupportable en dépenses
contraintes par rapport au niveau de
vie. Ça à l'époque j'étais avec monsieur
Dupourignant, on l'avait senti venir pas
la forme que ça allait prendre parce que
les gens confondent comment dire la
forme finale ou transitoire d'un
mouvement avec son origine. Si on est un
peu connecté aux classes populaire
françaises là en l'occurrence aux
classes moyennes, on sent un moment
d'exaspération. Par contre la forme
qu'elle va prendre, ça c'est la liberté
de l'histoire et c'est la liberté du
peuple. Mais il y a des gens qui n'ont
jamais conscience si vous voulez de de
en fait du prix des choses. Euh on a des
exemples. On a vu monsieur Copé avec
c'est pas en chocolat mais je pourrais
vous en citer d'autres. Vo moi j'avais
un ancien patron par exemple qui je me
souviens une patronne en l'occurrence
qui m'avait envoyé acheter un petit
déjeuner pour l'équipe. Une fois plus
c'est des anecdotes mais ça en fait ça
dit tellement de choses. Elle m'avait
donné je me souviens un billet de 50 je
me souviens c'était orange un billet de
50 € pour aller acheter trois psycholat.
Elle comprenait pas que je lui ramène de
la monnaie, mais elle comprenait pas en
mode comment quelque chose de de
difficile à comprendre
intellectuellement. Elle le comprenait
pas en sensoriellement presque comme un
impression comme une un défaut
d'impressionnisme. Ce sont des gens qui
sont déconnectés des sentiments de la du
ressenti des gens. Bon là, on le voit,
on va peut-être pas faire de la
politique politicienne, c'est pas le
but. Mais on voit bien là, monsieur
Berou qui pense parler aux gens et
parler aux responsabilités des gens et
qui dit "On est tous responsables et
vous avez tous croqué la dette." Et en
fait provoquant une indignation légitime
qui est pas une indignation de la gauche
contre la droite ou de l'extrême gauche
contre je ne sais quoi ou l'extrême
droite ou n'importe quoi, une
indignation populaire face à un
phénomène qui n'est pas de leur fait. Et
en fait, on voit que monsieur Berou
paradoxalement sincèrement ne comprend
pas puisqu'il insiste les mois qu'il
provoquent en disant une absurdité
pareille. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a 90 % de
la population française qui va prendre
le fait d'être accusé d'être responsable
de la dette comme une insulte
fondamentale et en face un premier
ministre qui de tout qui de toute
évidence avec sa sincérité croit dire
une vérité aux gens alors qu'il dit un
mensonge. Mais c'est là le rôle du
politique et et la difficulté aussi je
profite petite de de cette émission d'
un peu le temps pour donner peut-être
cette expérience là aussi la plupart des
hommes politiques sont pas forcément
corrompus ou malhonnêtes. qui sont
dépassés par des réalités qu'ils ne
veulent pas voir. Et le temps passant,
le général disait "La vieillesse c'est
un naufrage", il le disait aussi par
vous voyez cette succession de couche
que de réalité parallèle que les
responsables politiques vivent un moment
ils sont étouffés par elle. Pas parce
que c'est des salots et bah ce qu'ils ne
savent pas s'en extraire. Le général lui
avait réussi à le faire mais c'est
difficile et si ça se trouve moi-même je
suis dedans sans m'en rendre compte.
On fait comment pour reconnecter tout ça
et avoir un pays qui peut trouver des
consensus pour avancer, pour résister à
la guerre économique, pour résister à la
pénurie de matière première, à la
désindustrialisation parce qu'on a pas
d'énergie bon marché. On fait comment
pour éviter que ça explose ? Et on fait
comment pour reconnecter nos élites ? La
première des choses, c'est faire en
sorte qu'on respecte vraiment les
élections. Alors, ça va paraître tout
bête, ça va paraître tout simple, mais
d'ailleurs, vous voyez bien, toute
revendication autour du respect de la
parole donnée, du pouvoir que le peuple
transfère à ses dirigeants euh est
considéré comme du populisme. Alors, le
populisme est devenu une insulte. Alors,
à la démagogie, c'est une insulte. Mais
le populisme, moi, je m'en réclame et on
n'est pas très nombreux. Enfin, on a un
certain nombre à s'en réclamer. Pourquoi
? Car il n'y a rien de déshonorant à
réclamer obéir au peuple. Et obéir au
peuple, ce n'est pas lui dire que le
peuple a toujours raison, une absurdité
en soi parce que le peuple n'est pas une
personne, c'est un intérêt collectif
mais qu'il faut toujours lui obéir même
si on estime qu'il a tort. Et si on
estime qu'il a tort, et bien on se met
en retrait de sa propre vanité et on
essaie de convaincre la population
française, le corps électoral
majoritairement qu'on avait raison. Mais
on ne peut jamais s'imposer face au
peuple. Et c'est vraiment
fondamentalement ce qui diffère. Euh si
on voit nos voisins, j'ai parlé du
Royaume-Uni tout à l'heure, qui euh bon,
ils avaient un peu de de ressources euh
d'hydrocarbure, bon enfin ça allait pas
très pas loin euh mais qui est dans une
situation assez semblable à la France
par la population, par la culture, euh
par un certain nombre de valeurs, par
l'anciété de la démocratie euh sur nos
territoires. Même quand on était en en
ancien régime, il y avait des formes de
démocratie populaire, de consultation,
de ce qu'ils appelaient les communes, de
ce qu'on appelait dans les villes. Il y
a toujours une forme de de consultation.
Donc, on est très proche du Royaume-Uni,
mais par exemple la Suisse qui est un
pays sans ressources qui pendant
longtemps a eu un retard euh dans
l'éducation euh de de sa population qui
est isolée, qui n'a même pas accès au
maire, arrive à avoir un niveau de vie
considérable. Bien, la première force de
la suite, c'est d'obéir à son peuple.
c'est d'être une démocratie la plus
directe possible et d'avoir transformé
la vraie richesse. Moi, je suis un
admirateur de de de Jean Baudin, il de
richesse que d'homme. Ça veut pas dire
quand Jean Baudin dit ça que faut faire
raquer les gens et les passer en
esclavage. C'est pas ça la richesse des
hommes. La richesse des hommes, c'était
considéré qu'il y a des individus qui
sont individuellement et collectivement
des richesses et que c'est par eux qu'on
peut avancer et que toute contrainte
peut sembler fonctionner à court terme
mais qu'au moyen terme et au long terme,
toute contrainte d'une force hors sol
contre des individus nous amène à la
catastrophe. Euh et la Suisse montre au
sein de l'Europe, d'ailleurs faut voir à
quel point on parle peu de la Suisse,
euh comment la Suisse est méprisée, voir
caricaturée, parce qu'en fait le modèle
euh que la Suisse porte et apporté
portera, j'espère pour euh ce noble euh
pays euh est en fait une clé de lecture
euh pour les problèmes que nous avons
euh que nous avons euh en France. Donc
la première des choses pour reconnecter,
personne le vous savez le le pouvoir
absolu corrom absolument. Faut se
souvenir de vieilles doctrines qui ont
été établies et que sur lequel le temps
n'a pas fait une ride. Tout homme et
toute femme peut devenir corrompu, soit
corrompu moralement, soit corrompu
financièrement, soit corrompu, comme
disait le général, je dis tout à
l'heure, par sa propre vieillesse, par
ses propres vies, par sa
le propre les propres contraintes de sa
propre vie tout simplement. Voilà. Et
donc l'élection où c'est pas juste poser
un bulletin dans une urne ou un
coquillage noir ou un coquillage blanc,
c'est rappeler
aux élites qu'elles ne sont rien moment
et que tu dois servir. Voilà. Et donc
reconnecter les élites, c'est par la
contrainte du vote et le vote doit faire
force à la loi. Voilà. Et il faut aussi
que notre peuple propre peuple, en tout
cas le peuple français dans la relation
de sincérité que qu'on doit avoir avec
lui doit parfois ne pas laisser faire
des forfaitures démocratiques. La
première grande crise française, c'est
évidemment le vote contre la
Constitution européenne qui n'a pas été
intégré. Et en fait, à partir de là,
vous voyez tous les vices français, on
l'a encore vu l'année dernière. Bon euh
le fait par exemple, moi je suis contre
évidemment euh que un premier ministre
de gauche dirige mon pays, mais les
françaises et les Français ont donné
plus de députés de gauche que de députés
du rasso national ou euh des amis de
monsieur Atal et monsieur Macron. Je le
regrette. Je me suis donné coréam pour
pas qu'ils aient plus de députés que
nous, mais ils en ont plus. Donc
monsieur Macron aurait dû appeler un
premier ministre de gauche a priori et
on aurait vu ce qui s'est passé. Le fait
qu'il se permettent de ne tenir aucun
compte des élections, même faire
semblant, voilà, en disant je vais
convoquer un premier ministre de gauche,
je sais qu'il va pas tenir, mais au
moins on aura respecté cette étape
symbolique. Et donc le fait que nos
dirigeants ne respectent même pas les
étapes symboliques principielles de la
démocratie y compris représentative, je
parle même pas de la démocratie
semidirecte ou directe, c'est le mal
français et c'est un mal qui est
récurrent en France puisque
l'effondrement de la deè de la 2è
République, c'est le mépris pour le
suffrage universel et c'est le peuple
qui préfère paradoxalement l'Empire à la
République tellement la République a
méprisé ses propres principes.
l'effondrement de la 3e République,
c'est entre les entre les une fois plus
entre les deux guerres l'incompréhension
et l'incapacité d'entendre le peuple
français, de se réformer lui-même. La
4è, bref, c'est un mal français. Voilà
ce, comment dire cette profonde rupture
organisée par les élites françaises
elles-mêmes de considérer qu'elles sont
toujours supérieures au à leurs citoyens
et que par nature elles ont un droit
supérieur à gouverner que le reste du de
des Français, c'est le mal congénital de
notre civilisation. Avant de parler un
petit peu alstom industrie et ainsi de
suite, vous avez été dans une commission
si mes souvenirs sont bons.
J'ai même présidé enfin j'en étais j'ai
été dans plusieurs commissions. J'ai été
pris commission souveraineté
énergétique, la commission sur la
souveraineté industrielle, sur la
souveraineté agricole. Voilà, j'ai un
petit peu tendance à être souverainiste
caricatural et j'ai été aussi président
de la la commission d'enquête sur les
ingérences étrangères.
On commence par souveraineté
énergétique.
Faim,
c'est quoi ?
C'est un scandale, c'est une mauvaise
décision, c'est prolonger les courbes
d'un parti qui avait décidé de fermer
pour avoir une un vote écologiste. C'est
quoi ?
Mais c'est la conjonction de de
plusieurs phénomènes qui paradoxalement
on n'aurait rien dû avoir à faire
ensemble et qui se sont retrouvés mêlés.
Le premier phénomène, on en parle moins
que les autres, c'est l'ingérence
allemande et en partie suisse d'ailleurs
aussi. Bon, mais c'est avant tout
l'ingérence allemande. C'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre ? pas un
hasard si Fenheim c'est en Alsace et
c'est à la frontière allemande. Ça
faisait des années que au-delà du
nucléaire en général, les Allemands
attaquer l'existence de la centrale de
Fessenheim et voulait en fait prolonger
leur propre politique énergétique,
peut-être qu'on y reviendra, qui
consistait à se débarrasser du nucléaire
allemand et se débarrasser du nucléaire
français et considérant que le fait que
la France est à sa frontière une
centrale nucléaire était un danger. Et
en fait les mensonges très organisés
autour des dangers de Fenheim à savoir
que c'était soisant sur une faille
sismique que c'était pas loin du rein,
que c'était la plus vieille centrale
française en âge tous ces mensonges qui
en fait ne reposaient sur rien puisque
tous les rapports sur les rapports
parlementaires qui ont suivi assemblée
Sénat mais aussi le rapport même de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire sur
Fessenheim indiquait bien que Fenheim
malgré son âge entre guillemets était
une centrale parfaitement sûre
parfaitement entretenue
même mieux entretenu que des centrales
plus récentes. Mais enfin, je vais pas
rentrer là-dedans parce qu'après certain
nombre de gens de d'adversaires
politiques parce que ça on y reviendra
peut-être après retourne le langage
scientifique et technique qui est d'une
grande rigueur. Certains politiciens et
politiciennes utilisent en fait la
faiblesse de la rigueur à savoir le fait
qu'elle ne mente pas pour eux mentir. Ça
on y reviendra mais je veux pas mélanger
les choses. Donc l'Allemagne a fait une
pression extrêmement forte pour fermer
Fenheim. Première premier phénomène au
sens philosophique du terme. Deuxième
phénomène effectivement vous l'avez
sous-entendu, des accords électoraux,
les verrs français mais les verrs en
Europe mais en général compris par des
financements l'industrie gazière.
Russ
russe. Oui. Mais là c'est pour les pour
les verts c'est plus compliqué à
trouver. Je parle les verts les verts
allemands.
Les verts allemands. Oui. Oui. Mais par
contre ce qui est avéré est encore très
facilement vérifiable, c'est que aussi
les socio-démocrates parce que les
socio-démocrates allemand monsieur
Schreuder, je sais pas s'il l'a encore
mais enfin pendant longtemps a eu son
jeton de présence et le salaire qui va
avec euh à la tête de Gazprom, enfin pas
de Gazprom, du gazoduc. Je sais plus
c'est Nordstream 1 ou Nordstream 2.
Enfin un des deux gazoduc qui relie
directement la Russie à l'Allemagne en
passant au-dessus de nos de leurs petits
amis Polonais et Baltes. Euh comment
dire ? Monsieur Schroder était prenez
son ticket. Je sais pas s'il le prend
toujours, mais j'ai pas envie de dire
d'une bêtise, mais en tout cas il l'a
pris pendant longtemps. Bref, les
Allemands ont saccagé le nucléaire pas
par vertu, mais euh comment dire pour
affaiblir la France et l'industrie
nucléaire au passage. Mais ça, on pourra
y revenir aussi. Il y avait quand même
beaucoup d'argent derrière. Bon,
deuxième phénomène et le socialistes par
pur opportunisme, d'ailleurs tout le
monde peut aller voir la vidéo
l'audition de François Hollande qui
concluait un peu cette cette commission
d'enquête sur la souveraineté
énergétique. La façon dont il parle de
la fermeture de Fessenheim avec beaucoup
de légèreté, de distance, de désintérêt
en fait fondamentalement dit tout cet
accord. Donc effectivement Martin Aubri
à l'époque secrétaire première
secrétaire fédérale du Parti socialiste
a fait un accord avec madame Duflot des
verts pour fermer au moins Fessenheim et
ensuite les macronistes reprendront la
promesse 14 réacteurs nucléaires. Et
donc vous avez cette conjonction,
c'est-à-dire la plus un dessin de très
long terme, le dessin allemand
d'affaiblir la souveraineté énergétique
française et une technologie sur
lesquelles ils étaient inférieurs à
nous. Et l'autre dessin minable euh
complètement conructurel, un accord
électoral euh qui tombe aussitôt qu'il
est euh exercé euh fait fermer un outil
industriel français très important. Donc
il y a la souveraineté énergétique
elle-même, il y a l'électricité qui a
été produite à Fessenheim, il y a les
emplois, il faut quand même pas
l'oublier, des emplois très qualifiés,
très bien rémunérés.
Et il y a aussi une perte de valeur pour
la France. Oui, on perd on pas on parle
sans cesse de la dette. La dette, c'est
des chèqus qui ont été fait sur le dos
des contribuables français. Euh mais
c'est aussi le fait d'avoir abîmé des
biens publics et Fenheim, c'est un bien
public, c'est-à-dire que il y avait sa
fermeture, j'ai envie de dire l'année
même et le fait qu'il fallait combler
mais il y a toute la richesse que devait
produire cet outil pendant 10 20 40 ans.
Parce qu'en fait
richesse en terme de savoir-faire, de
formation, même le flux d'électrons,
vous avez un flux d'électrons qui sort,
c'est une richesse puisqueà partir de
l'énergie qui sort, les électrons qui
sortent, vous pouvez faire bah de
l'industrie lourde, même du tourisme.
tourisme, bah il consomme de
l'électricité. Voilà, toute activité
économique euh consomme de
l'électricité. Donc si vous avez une
électricité qui est peu cher et si vous
vendez un service qui est plus cher, bah
vous créez de la valeur économique pour
le territoire. C'est un b à bas mais
enfin certains ont pas l'air d'avoir
compris cette règle pourtant très simple
euh et très compréhensible par tous.
Donc Fenheim, j'ai parlé du référendum
pour la la blessure démocratique.
Faenheim, c'est vraiment une autre
trahison et c'est une blessure profonde
et d'ailleurs, j'ai fait passer un
amendement récemment pour réouvrir
Fessenheim lors d'une d'une discussion
loi sur l'énergie. Bon bref,
c'est plus possible.
Je vais vous dire aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué de savoir où en sont les
travaux mais moi je l'ai dit dans la
défense de mon amendement. C'est aussi
une un vote symbolique, c'est qu'il faut
établir la vérité sur Fenheim, pas juste
pour euh mettre des têtes sur un peak.
Euh c'est surtout pour que les Français
sachent ce qui s'est passé. Car euh moi
dans mon combat politique, alors je
parlais à mon titre à titre personnel,
il y a l'avenir. Faut préparer l'avenir,
mais je ne crois pas qu'on prépare
l'avenir sur des mensonges. Donc il y a
un certain nombre de faits, c'est pour
ça aussi que je suis très pénible sur
Alstom, mais Fonam, il est directement
lié en l'occurrence. Euh, on peut pas
construire sur des mensonges. Donc, si
le corps électoral, nos concitoyens
n'ont pas conscient de ce qui s'est
passé concrètement, précisément avec
Fessenheim, je pense qu'ils n'auront pas
les clés de lecture et les informations
qui leur comprendront de faire des choix
éclairés pour la suite. Car on en
revient à ce que je disais, moi j'ai
essayé d'être cohérent avec la
démocratie. Pour moi, le peuple est
souverain, mais il lui faut les clés de
compréhension et toutes les
informations, y compris les informations
qui ne me plaisent pas. Parce qu'il y a
des informations qui me déplaisent.
Toute famille politique a fait des
erreurs.
C'est pour ça qu'on reçoit l'ensemble du
spectre politique chez nous. On n pas
beaucoup reçu des gens du RN. Donc c'est
pour ça qu'on se rattrape aujourd'hui.
Euh lors de votre commission sur la
souveraineté énergétique et sur le
nucléaire, est-ce que vous avez
auditionné des gens concernant les
capacités de la France à se fournir en
uranium chez ses principaux fournisseurs
? Est-ce que il y a eu un phénomène de
prospective concernant la disponibilité
des ressources en uranium chez les
différents fournisseurs mondiaux ?
Est-ce qu'il y a eu une anticipation sur
la ruée de l'uranium avec toute cette
nucléarisation du monde en terme civil
de construction de réacteurs en Chine,
de construction réacteur un peu partout
dans le monde ? Est-ce que la France
s'est un petit peu réveillée pour faire
de la prospective et de l'anticipation
sur cette clé de notre industrie et de
notre souveraineté ?
Non, pas du tout. Alors, on pourrait
faire une émission entière là-dessus. En
fait, c'est assez tragique et ça paraît
tellement absurde et simple.
que certains sans doute vont croire que
je mens mais tout le monde pourra
vérifier. Euh en fait, à partir des
années 90 et surtout 2000, euh certain
nombre de dirigants français, de toute
façon tout est public, hein, estiment en
fait que le nucléaire, enfin la fission
nucléaire, les réacteurs de 3e
génération ou 3e amélioré comme paire
euh sont en fait une technologie
mourante et qui ne va pas prospérer. Euh
et donc euh on avait une technologie en
France, on avait beaucoup d'avance, on
avait franchement au moins un
demi-siècle d'avance sur les Russes et
les Américains et puis alors à l'époque
les Chinois, j'en parle même pas dans
les années 90, pas aujourd'hui. C'était
les gens ont peut-être entendu parler
réacteur phonix et réacteur super phnix.
Et en fait la technologie ces réacteurs
de 4e génération plusieurs technologies
mais celle-là donc la la technologie de
Phenniix et Super Phonix permettait ce
qu'on appelle de fermer le cycle
nucléaire. C'est-à-dire qu'à partir des
ressources dont la France dispose déjà
ou des ressources qui sont en abondance
sur terre parce qu'en fait la forme
d'uranium nécessaire pour les réacteurs
que nous aujourd'hui est très rare et
quasiment anecdotique par rapport aux
autres formes d'uranium comme on
pourrait utiliser dans d'autres
réacteurs. Bref, fermer ce cycle.
Permettez de ne plus se poser la
question que vous avez posé à savoir
est-ce qu'il y a encore d'uranium rare
euh suffisant pour les réacteurs et pour
une flotte de réacteur très importante
si l'Inde, la Chine évidemment s'y
mette. Euh et donc nos les grands
cerveaux sur patte euh qui ont euh
humilié, il faut bien le dire quand
même, humilié les vrais cerveaux qui
avaient permis à la France, qui n'a pas
de ressources naturelles, euh de
s'extraire de cette de ce mauvais coût
de du sort de la de la mauvaise
providence, euh ont donc fermé euh Super
Phenniix
euh et donc considérer qu'il y avait
plus besoin de fermer ce cycle, qu' il y
avait suffisamment d'uranium pour que
euh la technologie meurent. Bon bah et
ben non. Voilà. Donc c'est une fois plus
ces gens complètement absurdes qui
confondent une fois plus des pensées à 3
ans comme la leure avec des pensées à 30
voire 300 ans comme ceux qu'on fait le
programme nucléaire français ou ailleurs
se sont complètement plantés. Et donc
effectivement on a en réserve beaucoup
d'uranium pour tenir à court terme je
crois plus il y a 3 ou 5 ans de réserve
d'uranium pour que les réacteurs
fonctionnent en France mais nous n'avons
plus de contrôle suffisant de la
ressource. Alors, ils nous disent "Oui,
mais il y a suffisamment d'uranium dans
suffisamment de pays, de de sources
d'uranium, pardon, dans suffisamment de
pays euh pour que la France soit
assurée. Il y a le Kazakhstan, il y a le
Canada, il y a l'Australie et on parle
il y a on parle toujours du Niger mais
bon, c'est vrai qu'en Australie, au
Kazakhstan, au Canada, il y en a il y en
a plus disponibilité mais en fait on l'a
vu avec le Covid espèce de raisonnement
de mondialistes qui considèrent qu'une
et ça c'est vraiment important. Les
Françaises et les Français vont entendre
à la télévision que même si nous ne
produisons pas de ressources ou de
matériel dans un pays, y compris de
l'alimentation, hein, nous sommes
souverains parce que les sources
d'approvisionnement soit-disant sont
suffisamment diverses, équilibrées pour
qu'on soit jamais en rupture de stock.
Bon, n'importe quoi. Tous les pays
peuvent se fermer à un moment ou l'a vu
avec le Covid. Et donc, les Français ont
découvert à la télévision qu'un certain
nombre de produits, par exemple les
graines de moutarde, dire la moutarde
c'est Dijon. Il paraît qu'il y a des
bourguignons euh et bien en fait la
moutarde de Dijon, les graines sont
canadiennes. Donc un un truc aussi
anecdotique où la tous les Français
pensaient ne jamais manquer une
moutarde, bah si en fait le Canada coupe
alors que c'est un pays amis, mais ils
peuvent couper pour plein de raisons et
ben il y a plus de moutarde en France.
Bon et ben alors imaginez bon pour la
moutarde on peut s'en passer quelques
mois
passer
et ben voilà je savais que j'allais
provoquer un accident diplomatique. Le
mais le le comment dire l'uranium on
peut pas alors on a un peu d'avance mais
c'est valable pour pour des choses
extrêmement graves. C'est pas que je
passe au coocalan he c'est que je suis
désolé dans ce sujet-là tout est dans
tout et la souveraineté ne se diffuse
pas. Aujourd'hui, vous avez des
françaises et des Français qui sont mal
soignés parce que nous ne sommes pas
souverains sur des médicaments, y
compris des médicaments anticancéreux et
que vous avez parce que des gens ont
considéré que avoir une filière
d'approvisionnement de de médicaments
contre le cancer dont les sources sont
l'Inde ou la Chine est aussi valable que
d'avoir des sources d'approvisionnement
en Normandie ou dans la vallée chimique
du Rô, et bien voilà le niveau de de
patriotisme et d'humanité de ces gens.
Moi je pense qu'on est souverain que si
on contrôle tout. En tout cas un maximum
qu'on peut contrôler, c'est pas le cas.
Et donc pour revenir sur le le nucléaire
à l'uranium, il s'agit pas de créer la
panique. Mais si un jour euh nos
approvisionnements, comment dire bah
donc le Kazakhstan, l'Australie, le
Canada se ferme ou si la Chine, l'Inde
ou d'autres pays qui se nucléarisent à
très grande vitesse, c'est la Chine
surtout qui je crois qu'ils en sont à
entre 8 et 10 réacteurs par an en ce
moment, se nucléarise très rapidement.
Euh et bien un jour il pourrai soit
directement prendre l'uranium pour eux,
soit indirectement dire "Écoutez, vous
êtes bien mignon, mais moi euh dans 20
ans, j'aurai le plus grand parc de euh
réacteur euh de 3e ou 3e plus génération
en fonction." Donc que vous me réservez
tout l'uranium et les petits français là
euh vous leur donnez ce qui reste. Donc
ce soit directement ou indirectement, on
pourrait être en tension sans parler du
prix euh qui pourrait augmenter. Donc
tout ça est tragique parce que ceux qui
ont lancé le programme nucléaire
français le savaient. On embrasse
Bernard Azambert.
Je ne connais pas ce monsieur, je vais
pas vous mentir. Mais il y en a d'autres
qui avaient pensé que je connais qui
avaient penser raisonner à ça. Ils
avaient prévu effectivement que la
technologie nucléaire telle que les
Français la connaissent était le début
d'une filière. C'était pas la fin. Il y
en a qui ont confondu le début et la
fin. Et lancer la filière nucléaire
française telle que l'a fait le général
de Gaulle avec d'autres sans penser le
cycle fermé, pas juste en papier le
faire concrètement. Ça consistait à
mettre en fait les Français en grande
difficulté et à leur mentir. Donc il
faut et c'est euh dans le programme que
Sport de manière très urgente relancer
euh euh le cycle fermé, reconquérir
cette technologie. Maintenant les
Chinois nous ont les Russes nous ont
nous ont copié, hein. En fait, ont
repris les Français ont laissé euh
comment dire à disposition, si je puis
dire, cette technologie. Bah, les Russes
et les Chinois, ils l'ont prise. Voilà.
Et donc, il faut absolument fermer le
cycle nucléaire. C'est une des urgences
nationales absolues.
Il y a eu des préconisations qui ont été
formulées dans cette commission. Est-ce
que ça fait l'effet d'un électrochoc ?
Est-ce que par exemple les services de
renseignement se sont dit bah tiens, on
va avoir une tension sur ce type
d'approvisionnement, ça va nous mettre à
mal ? Est-ce qu'il faut anticiper la
sécurisation ? Est-ce qu'il faut
resserrer nos liens avec certains pays ?
Est-ce que vous avez vu une évolution ?
Il y a rien. Moi, je je n'ai rien vu ni
directement ni indirectement. Mais si
vous voulez dire les services de
renseignement, ils ont une petite
autonomie, il faut pas qu'ils en aient
une trop grosse en démocratie. Euh mais
de toute façon, je pense qu'ils n'ont
pas eu d'instruction.
Je ne vois pas à quel moment ils
auraient eu d'instruction. Je veux dire,
que ce soit euh dans l'ordre, enfin
monsieur Ferat, ministre de l'énergie
aujourd'hui, je pense qu'il se moque
totalement. Alors, c'est un procès
d'intention. Oui, c'est un procès
d'intention mais enfin bon, je le
fréquente un peu, je débat avec lui de
temps en temps. Enfin, je
tout le monde
la suputation.
Oui, mais enfin bon, en tout cas, quand
je lui pose la question, il répond pas.
Donc s'il avait une réponse, je pense
qu'il la donnerait, il ferait le
entendu.
Je pense qu'il sait pas de quoi on parle
en fait.
Revenons au service de renseignement
sur les questions énergétiques. qui
juste là-dessus parce qu'on va dire
pourquoi il fait peut-être que monsieur
Ferat peut-être en l'occurrence je suis
injuste mais je crois pas mais en fait
on a eu le cas aussi dans cette
commission d'enquête parlementaire tout
c'est filmé hein moi une fois plus nous
sommes en démocratie donc il y a
beaucoup d'outils démocratiques don
j'encourage tout le monde à s'emparer
vous regardez par exemple l'audition de
de Nicolas Hullot c'est quand on sait
que cette personne est très populaire la
personne est sans doute très
sympathique. Il a sans doute fait des
choses pour la nature qui était sincère
quand il s'occupait pas de sa flotte de
véhicule personnel ou de prendre
l'hélico en disant qu'il fallait pas
polluer. Mais en dehors de de ces
quelques de ces quelques paradoxes, vous
écoutez Nicolas Hullot et bien vous
découvrez en direct qu'il ne sait même
pas les décrets qui signaient. Vous
savez sa directrice de crois que c'est
une femme, sa directrice de cabinet qui
est à côté de lui qui lui informe en
plein milieu de la commission, ce qui
est déjà plus ou moins interdit en fait.
euh que de l'informe de décision qu'il a
prise. Voilà, en direct devant tout le
monde, devant toute la France,
l'audition de Segolen Royal, vous
découvrez en direct que Segolen Royal
n'a strictement aucun souvenir, en tout
cas elle prétend le faire de ce qu'elle
a décidé. Vous écoutez madame Voinet qui
est une des ministres qui a fermé la
technologie Super Phenix, elle prétend
sur une autre technologie, la fusion que
l'élément nucléaire qui qui permet la
fusion et qu'est-ce qu'elle dit comme
nom ? Je sais plus. Enfinite une
molécule d'antidépresseur. Donc madame
Voinet qui est une des pièces maîtresses
de la politique antinucléaire de la
France depuis 30 ans, quand on la
confronte concrètement à comment
fonctionne une technologie qu'elle
combat, elle vous cite comme élément
atomique une molécule antidépressive. Je
précise que la voie est médecin en plus.
Elle a
peut-être fait elle a peut-être fait
voilà
Nobrium. Voà elle a parlé du Nobrium
pardon parce que c'était en homme. Donc
ça peut-être comme radium ou autre.
Voilà de de ténéronome. Ça a dû ça a dû
la troubler.
Ça arrive à tout le monde de mélanger
certains yom. Oui, ça arrive à tout le
monde mais si vous voulez c'est
thématiquel de toute façon tout le monde
peut regarder l'audition. Donc c'était
un gros morceau de glace quand même très
immergé de l'iceberg qui disait long de
de l'immensité qui restait sous la mer.
Revenons revenons aux préconisations de
nos antennes, de nos moustaches, de
notre flair, de nos fins liimiers.
Ils anticipent peut-être. Est-ce qu'il
vous alertent vous en tant que élu ?
Est-ce qu' ou est-ce qu'ils ne font
remonter ça que à la tête pensante ?
Alors moi je
est-ce que vous avez l'autorisation fin
du suspense ? Comment dire l'État
français les gouvernements enfin le
gouvernement et l'État français n'alerte
jamais les parlementaires. Ça n'existe
pas. De toute façon, tout le monde peut
regarder. Moi je suis à la commission
des finances, vous pouvez regarder
toutes les semaines les auditions qu'on
fait à la commission des finances.
Parallèlement à la commission des
affaires économiques, il n'y a quasiment
aucune information descendante. Euh les
informations qui viennent, c'est
systématique. Ça vient pas forcément de
moi. Par exemple, en commission des
finances, Charles Lecourson, euh député
centriste, anti-Rassemblon national,
voilà, euh est un des députés qui
apporte des informations à l'État
régulièrement. À ma petite échelle, j'ai
plusieurs fois apporté des informations
à l'État ou en tout cas, il prétendaient
ne pas les connaître. Donc en fait,
contrairement aux États-Unis ou d'autres
démocraties euh qui fonctionnent
paradoxalement bien mieux que nous, euh
en tout cas les parlementaires ont les
moyens de la faire fonctionner s'ils le
veulent, euh voilà, tout le monde peut
regarder, il n'y a jamais et même
parfois nous devons en fait contraindre
l'État, ses représentants à avouer des
informations qui sont publiques ou
presque publiques, qui parfois sont dans
la presse, mais qui sont difficiles à
faire cracher. Voilà. Donc c'est je suis
désolé, je n'ai jamais moi appris
quelque chose comme d'autres dis moi
parce que moi je peux parler que pour
moi mais enfin quand j'en parle avec mes
collègues qui s'y intéresse un peu c'est
pareil nous n'avons jamais rien appris
dans ces auditions. On essaie comment
dire de de de faire révéler des choses
mais une fois plus de tous les partis de
faire révéler des choses pour le public
pour nos concitoyens. Et souvent on sait
en avance qu'on veut essayer de faire
révéler ou faire dire. Mais il n'y a pas
en France cette culture
euh euh de l'information parlementaire.
Le une fois plus, on en revient avec la
triste actualité parlementaire, mais aux
dernières élections, le le Parlement en
France est considéré par
l'administration et l'exécutif qui sont
souvent les mêmes euh comme une
contrainte, un emmerdement. Voilà, le
parlement c'est des emmerdements, ça les
emmerde, c'est une contrainte. Alors bon
benah quand il y a des majorités
plétoriques, il y en a qui les avaient
appelé les Playmobil, moi je trouve que
c'était pas si mal. Oh là ça passe. Bon
euh il vote des truc bon et il y a
Tu sens un peu aigre.
Non non je suis pas aigre. C'est c'est
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait je déjà bon moi
j'essaie toujours un peu de de de de
jouer sur l'humour et la dérision pour
pas pleurer. Ça c'est une constance qui
m'évite de sombrer dans dans la
dépression et justement d'avoir de la
force pour me battre avec d'autres
évidemment. Mais c'est surtout moi j'ai
pas envie de cacher la vérité aux gens.
Moi je le veux dire quand vous avez on
parlait du nucléaire quand vous avez les
mêmes députés qui en 5 ans sont capables
d'appuyer sur un bouton pour fermer en
tout cas voter une loi qui ferme 14
réacteurs nucléaires et que les mêmes
députés sur leur même siège sur leurs
mêmes fesses appuyent sur un autre
bouton pour rouvrir 12 réacteurs
nucléaires sur 5 ans que trompe sur 50
ans. Bon et encore dans ce cas-là pour
moi il faut dégager mais qu'en 5 ans
vous ayez même pas c'est pas moi la
présence d'esprit de vous dire ah bah
dis donc il y a 5 ans, j'ai voulu fermer
12 réacteurs nucléaires. C'est-à-dire
bon je sais pas en valeur ça doit
représenter plus de 100 milliards
d'euros et là je vais dire je vais les
rouvrir enfin si ça devait m'arriver
peut-être que ça m'arrivera un jour un
truc comme ça et ben j'espère qu'il y
aura des gens qui me disent tang là il
est peut-être temps de prendre ta
retraite compris anticiper parce qu'être
capable vraiment de voter tout et son
contraire sur quelque chose qui ne
souffre aucun débat c'est-à-dire il y a
pas le contexte qui a changé la
technologie n'a pas changé il y a pas eu
un accident nucléaire entre les deux
enfin je sais pas toute excuse qui
aurait pu mener à un tel retournement
quand même. Bah non, ils ont voté la fin
des réacteurs. Après il faut qu' non euh
et hallucinant. Voilà. Et et moi ce
franchement moi je mes des collègues
députés qui ont voté ça et tout est le
contraire de tout et qui sont encore là
à se dire "Je mérite d'être député". Moi
je vous dis sincèrement pour moi ils
méritent pas d'être député. Alors, les
gens votent pour ce qu'ils veulent, ils
font ce qu'ils veulent mais moi je
trouve que c'est hallucinant et même
hallucinant de pas avoir la présence
d'esprit de dire bon allez, je me suis
tellement trompé, je me casse. Mais
vraiment, je je j'espère si un jour ça
devait m'arriver, je j'espère que le que
j'aurai la présence d'esprit de de
réagir quoi.
On sera là pour vous le rappeler.
Revenons revenons au au aux commissions.
Vous avez fait d'autres commissions ?
Euh donc énergie, souveraineté agricole
qu'on a pas pu finir à cause de la
dissolution malheureusement.
Souveraineté agricole, ça prenait quel
format ? Est-ce que vous avez réfléchi
un petit peu sur les intrans ? D'où
venez les intrans ? Comment fonctionnait
l'agriculture, le mercourd et tout le
tint toin ?
Bah sur les intrans, vous avez une
audition très intéressante de Yara qui
est donc l'entreprise une entreprise
norvégienne qui est une des dernières à
produire des engrais enfin produire des
engrais en Europe mais surtout à
importer des engrais en France. Bah
d'ailleurs, ils ont fermé récemment je
crois une zone d'importation à Nanterre
ou à Saint-Azer, je sais plus. Euh bon
bah vous aussi Yara. Bon ben il vous
explique, elle vous c'est une femme qui
dirige en France qui est très
intéressante. Bon bah qui vous explique
qu'on produit plus d'engrais en France
depuis longtemps, que ça n'a jamais
intéressé personne. Je crois que la
facture en moyenne sur 10 ans, ça va
être 4 milliards par an quelque chose
comme ça. Euh et puis surtout une fois
plus s' coupe si on coupe le le les
engrais c'est quoi ? C'est du minerais
mélangé à du gaz. Enfin je vous la
simplifie. Bon donc b on a ni l'un ni
l'autre. Donc ça impose une stratégie,
une conception peut-être produire de
l'hydrogène autrement par hydrolyse. Bon
bref, je vais pas vous on va pas comment
dire épiloguer mais mais il y a une
stratégie, il y a pas de stratégie. Et
là récemment dans mon je suis aussi
rapporteur spécial du de notre
contribution au budget européen. J'ai
auditionné des responsables du ministère
de de la de l'agriculture français de
fonctionnaires très honorable euh sur
justement les intran sur les engrais et
notamment je leur ai demandé bah alors
dans le cadre des grands projets de
souveraineté européenne s'en est où le
développement d'une filière d'engrais
européen ? Rien. Ah mais rien.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils m'ont dit mais c'est
intéressant, c'est-à-dire que ces
fonctionnaires euh ne m'ont pas dit que
c'était pas nécessaire. Ils ne m'ont pas
dit queil y avait pas eu la demande qui
avait faite à la de la France qui avait
été faite à la Commission européenne.
Ils m'ont dit ça n'avance pas. Et alors
pourquoi je l'avais demandé à l'époque,
c'est qu'il y avait une une actualité,
c'est que le Parlement européen a voté
des sanctions contre le régime de
Vladimir Poutine pour amplifier les les
taxes, je crois, ou je sais des taxes ou
des sanctions sur les engrais. Sauf que
si vous taxez des des des importations
dont vous êtes dépendant, ce n'est pas
le régime que vous taxez, que vous
sanctionnez, c'est vous-même. Voilà, ils
ont pas l'air de comprendre. Voilà, vous
ne pouvez sanctionner un régime, y
compris un régime hostile, que si ça lui
fait du mal. Si vous prenez une sanction
qui vous fait du mal à vous et pas à
l'autre, parce que vous en êtes
dépendant et que vous avez jamais eu
l'idée de développer une filière
là-dessus ou une autre pour vous passer
de sa dépendance, c'est lui qui a le
pouvoir. He Napoléon disait "La main qui
donne est supérieure à la main qui
tend." Donc vous, c'est nous qui tendons
la main pour avoir de l'engrais parce
que sans engrais il y a plus
d'agriculture européenne et c'est la
Russie malheureusement, je le regrette
qui sur ce produit là à la main comme
tant d'autres.
C'est c'est un petit peu aussi notre
effort de guerre.
Oui, tout est pas d'efforts de guerre
aujourd'hui. Il n'y a pas de politique
d'efforts de guerre qui soi mené quand
on entend y compris des médias.
Il y a une politique financière.
Regardez comment les Français euh
on achète beaucoup américains. Oui.
C'est-à-dire qu'on achète beaucoup, on
amplifie beaucoup nos dépendances, on
nourrit nos dépendances. Voilà. On
dépense beaucoup d'argent. Alors, il y a
des pays qui l'assument. des pays qui
sont sous protectorat américains parce
que occupés avec des occup des
occupations mais des bases militaires,
l'Italie, l'Allemagne, d'autres pays,
bon bah ils ou qu'une relation spéciale
comme le Royaume-Uni, bon bah ils
assument avoir des flux financiers très
réguliers que les États-Unis, bon Donald
Trump ne s'en cachent pas parce qu' il
dit que les pays membres de l'OTAN,
particulier ceux qui ont le privilège
entre guillemets d'avoir des soldats
américains sur leur sol doivent
contribuer à 2 % puis après 2 % ce
serait plutôt 5 et qu'en fait Trump dit
pas ah bah grâce au 5 % l'Allemagne va
avoir une industrie nationale qui va
permettre de faire un mur d'acier face à
la Russie ils disent bah grâce à ça on
va avoir plein de commandes et
l'industrie américaine va très bien.
Donc ils le disent en fait il y a même
pas de secret il suffit d'écouter et de
pas avoir envie d'entendre ce que
certains racontent. Bon on amplifie
cette dépendance. Bon bah sur les
engrais c'est exactement la même chose.
Et je vais vous donner un exemple très
concret parce on revient sur les
engrais. Désolé, j'ai j'ai un peu
parfois l'esprit d'escalier. Euh les
engraiss, les les sanctions notamment
sur le milieu agricole avec la Russie,
de mémoire, c'est 2014 les premières
sanctions. Euh je me souviens parce qu'à
l'époque ça concernait beaucoup les
éleveurs et les producteurs de pommes
par exemple en France. Bon bref, euh en
2014, on se dit "Bon, Vladimir Poutine a
un régime hostile aux intérêts européens
et de ses pays membres, soit euh
tirons-en les conséquences. On est
dépendant du gaz russe, on est dépendant
du pétrole russe, de tout un tas de
métaux que
titane
du titane de certaines matières
radioactives qui permettent de soigner
les gens sur les cancers et tout ça.
Vous remarquez ça, je l'ai fait avouer à
Panacher une fois en commission, il y
avait jamais de suit de suite. Euh et
des engrais bon que des choses vitales.
Oh, c'est une broutille.
Bon euh ce qu'on met en place, une
planification, moi j' préféré française
mais à la limite une planification
européenne si ça leur fait plaisir sur
ces produits-là. Bon ben non. Alors
c'est pas il y a 1 an 2 ans, c'était il
y a 13 ans 12 ans. Il s'est rien passé.
Pas juste le lancement d'un truc qui
aurait pas marché. On peut lancer
quelque chose qui marche pas. Le général
de Gaulle lance le plan calcul. Ça a
apporté des choses, ça a pas apporté ce
que le général de Gaulle voulait. Bon,
on peut se planter. C'est ridicule de
dire que si on lance quelque chose, ça
va marcher à Force Thory. Mais on a ils
ont rien lancé.
Même pas un petit ar de la licorne de la
startup.
Oui, peut-être un machin qui a eu un
petit chèque pour faire une présentation
PowerPoint. Mais mais concrètement, il y
a rien. Et en plus, on a un acteur
norvégien. Alors, il est pas dans
l'Union européenne, mais enfin, c'est un
ami, il est dans le marché commun. Euh,
il est quand même la Norvège est quand
même liée à l'Atlantisme. Bon, bref, euh
on pourrait avoir fait une filière euh
voilà, avec le gaz norvégien ou le gaz
du Royaume-Uni ou ce qui reste euh
Pays-Bas. Bon, on aurait pu faire oui,
il reste pas beaucoup
peut-être même d'ailleurs
un peu trop de problème.
Enfin, bon, en tout cas, les Norvégiens
et les en tout cas les Norvégiens, il
leur en reste suffisamment. D'ailleurs,
ils ont eu un record de ressources
financières du gaz en en 2000 entre 2020
et 2022
avec un fond souverain très agressif,
très agressif. Et puis enfin, moi je je
trouve que c'est un modèle de gestion
démocratique pour les Norvégiens, mais
pour nous ça les moins euh voilà, mais
le comment vous dire le le le bref, on
aurait pu le faire, ça les intéresse
pas. Moi, je vais vous donner, c'est une
toute petite anecdote parce que je sais
très bien que ça peut pas remplacer les
choses. Il se trouve que dans ma
circonscription euh à côté de Douland
euh dans une ville qui s'appelle une
commune qui s'appelle Boval euh qui est
une friche industrielle par ailleurs,
mais ça c'est pas le sujet, il y a une
ancienne mine de potace. C'est une toute
petite mine évidemment, c'est pas les
super minees qu'on a aujourd'hui. Et à
quelques kilomètres dans le Pas de Calé,
on avait peut-être, vous vous en
souvenez, une entreprise à Masengarde
qui stockait, comment dire, vous savez,
dans des grosses boules là qui
stockaient justement ces engrais azotés.
Je sais pas si vous souvenez quand ça a
fermé, c'était les ouvriers qui
maintenaient les produits sous sécurité
pour parce que c'est très dangereux,
c'est ce qui a explosé au Liban. Bon euh
bref, donc c'était les ouvriers qui
protégeaient la France de la cupidité de
de des actionnaires une fois de plus.
Euh bon bref, donc à quelques
kilomètres, vous aviez si vous voulez
une solution industrielle et une
solution entre guillemets de matière
première, en tout cas une petite mine.
Évidemment que c'est pas avec cette
petite mine et cette usine euh qu'on va
euh euh remplacer les Russes, mais c'est
symbolique. J'ai appelé le pr les
préfets enfin les trois préfets qui se
sont suicidés dans la Somme. Je l'ai
signalé au ministère de l'économie, je
me suis agité là-dessus. Rien du tout.
M'a dit "Ah oui, c'est compliqué parce
que la mine est devenue une décharge."
Oui, c'est devenu une décharge. Et
alors, j'ai pas l'impression que sortir
les ordures d'une mine, ce soit très
compliqué. Bon bref pour eux mais en
fait une fois plus c'est même pas que
c'était compliqué en fait ils en avaient
rien à faire
rien à [__] Voilà il y a pas plus
loin que ça. Ah oui ok c'est ça ça ne
les intéresse pas
mais c'est une blague.
Ben non vous pouvez vérifier il y a une
ancienne mine à Beauoval. Il y a il y
avait l'usine de Mazingarde pas loin.
D'ailleurs, c'est je crois que c'est le
député Bruno Bild qui est député du
coin. Euh voilà mais ça les intéresse
pas. Mais quand le le
ça les intéresse pas ou ils comprennent
pas ? Bah vous allez dire après c'est
comme ce que j'ai dit sur Ferat que je
suis odieux. Bon
j'ai pas encore dit que vous étiez au
non mais mais je veux dire le le c'est
vrai qu'il y a un côté présentieux dans
ce que je dis dire bah oui de stribuer
les bons points et tout mais je veux
dire je vais pas non plus me cacher
derrière mon petit doigt et faire ah oui
bah peut-être qu'en fait c'est quelqu'un
de bien mais qui est contraint par la
vie la société. Non mais ces gens ont
tous les pouvoirs, ils sont très bien.
Vous êtes député vous avez 6000 par mois
vous êtes ministre vous avez entre 12 et
15000. Euh non, tout va bien. Bon donc
s'ils prennent pas ces décisions, c'est
qu'ils ne le veulent pas. Mais il ça ne
les intéresse pas. Mais je reviens sur
mes histoire de de on ferme 14 nuclé, on
ferme enfin on vote la la fermeture de
14, on vote la réouverture enfin le
maintien de 12.
Je en fait il ils s'en foutent.
Tant que ça roule, ça marche. Mais
regardez le le le le le le médicament
pendant le Covid, les gens se rendent
compte inquiet à juste raison qu'on est
dépendant des principes actifs qui
viennent soit d'Inde, soit de Chine et
les fameux masques où les pays européens
en étaient à faire du raquette et à
jouer au plus gros mafieux sur le tarmac
des aéroports pour savoir qu'il pouvait
prendre le lot de masque l'un sur
l'autre. Bon euh on en était là, on en
était réduit là. Euh bon, ah oui, alors
on a compris euh les pénurés
médicaments, c'est fini. Grand plan de
relocalisation des du principes, des
principe actif, euh la transformation,
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir.
Oui, on va commencer par les par les
médicaments pour le cancer quand enfin
pour lutter contre le cancer quand même,
le curar pour comment dire la
réanimation. Ah, vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir. Bon, je vais vous dire,
j'ai même j'ai une confession à faire à
ce moment-là.
Attendez.
Innominé patri spirit s. Allez-y.
Je peux euh Je sais pas ce que vous
allez me donner comme Je sais pas ce que
vous allez donner comme pénitence.
Le fouet.
Je me suis dit je me suis dit bon
mfiez-vous, il y en a certains
l'assemblée qu'il aiment. J'ai j'ai euh
comment dire
j'ai bah personne ne veut savoir mais il
y a un article qui a dit le comment vous
dire le le le blague à part. J'ai
vraiment cru à ce moment-là, je me suis
dit c'était tellement grave, on s'est
tellement retrouvé à poil sur
l'alimentation, sur les engrais, sur les
sur les médicaments, sur la vie des gens
avec voilà des des des Françaises et des
Français, des gens d'autres pays
européens qui ont pas eu la réanimation
parce que il y a même manquait pas de
curar, des médecins, des soignants, je
leur en veux pas les pauvres, ça devait
être les décisions les plus dures de
leur choix qu'on parfois alors pas
forcément en France, en Italie par
exemple dû faire des choix sur qui est
prioritaire, qui est pas euh je dis là
c'est tellement grave que va avoir un
avant, un après. Je vous le je
sincèrement sans aucun cynisme que je
cru. Bon, je me suis trompé.
Bon, j'ouvre une parenthèse. Vous croyez
en quelque chose ? En Dieu ?
Non, moi je suis stoïicien. Je trouve
qu'on a rien apporté de neuf depuis 2000
ans là-dessus.
Alors, je vous ferai pas
J'aurais pas dû dire ça, je vais avoir
des problèmes.
Je vous je vous ferai pas réciter 18
fois notre père. Non. Mais par contre,
j'ai une culture et je remercie mes
parents, j'ai une culture catholique
et je suis sorti euh de ma de la
croyance de mes pères et de mes mères
euh en pleine conscience. Ça c'est mal
et ça, j'en suis fier.
Parenthèse fermée, donc pas d'amis
imaginaire.
Bon ami, mais moi je je veux peut-être
une richesse. Les croyants disent
souvent que pour eux c'est une richesse.
Je veux bien le croire effectivement
avoir un soutien euh une vertu. Euh
voilà. Alors gendarmeon disait que les
athés étaient encore plus admirables
parce qu'ils faisaient le bien sans
pression extérieure. Si je suis dire bon
je donnerai pas ça d'ailleurs je suis
même pas spécialement arrêté. J'ai je
suis agnostique j'ai pas de prétention à
avoir un
apost
non aposta non parce que ça pourrait
dire que j'ai cru et puis qu'en plus il
y a un côté quand même je rond avec la
religion j'ai rien contre la religion
catholique j'ai rien contre la religion
de mes pères ou de mes mères d'ailleurs
j'ai aucune aucune hostilité
particulière si je veux pas mentir je
connais beaucoup de gens je fais
beaucoup d'admiration d'ailleurs ils le
savent pour ceux qui sont concernés pour
les vrais croyants et les vrais
pratiquants surtout avec les
implications morales sur l'aide à autru
que ça implique et la charité voilà j'ai
moins de respect pour ceux qui font
croire qu'ils sont très croyants et
visiblement en tout cas ils ont pas
l'air très pratiquant
Allez, parenthèse fermée. Revenons à
cette anticipation, ce cap. Donc comme
j'ai j'ai pu l'entendre de votre bouche,
nous avons un capitaine, nous avons des
matelots qui anticipent les coups de
vent. On sait où on va la France avec
cette souveraineté énergétique et
alimentaire si bien gérée, vous le
sentez comment pour les cinq prochaines
années à venir ? S'il y a des tensions
géopolitiques qui s'accentuent, si on se
fâche tout rouge, tout rouge, tout
rouge, tout rouge avec les Russes, avec
les Chinois, avec les Indiens, qu'on est
en laiss par les Five Eats-Unis en tête,
qu'on s'est fait ouvrir en long, en
large en travers en terme de data, en
terme de tout un tas de choses.
Vous le sentez comment ? J'ai pas besoin
de le sentir, je je je le constate.
Vous aurez pu me poser cette question en
2012 quand je m'engage en politique
parce que j'avais des espèces
d'intuition, des choses que j'avais vu,
pressenti, analysé. Bon bref, un peu
plus ça va paraître prétentieux mais là
aujourd'hui tout est sur la table. Je
dis ce que vous tout ce que vous avez
décrit Five Ey les
bah c'est les cinq pays qui ont enfin
les cinq pays anglo-saxons qui se sont
unis pour comment ça s'appelait ?
échelon euh depuis le programme échelon
pour comment dire espionner, se partager
des informations avec des très grandes
oreilles. À l'époque, c'est le
téléphone, les câbles. Maintenant, c'est
j'imagine que le le l'accord a dû a dû
s'étendre à toutes les technologies
possibles et inimaginable. Enfin, tout
le monde sait que même le directeur de
la DGSI ou DGSE, je ne sais plus àel
parce qu'il a fait les deux, je sais
plus à quel moment de sa carrière, il
l'a dit.
Vous parlez vous parlez de Nicolas
Lerner.
Nicolas Lner. Oui, il a dit qu'il y
avait des des effectivement des antennes
très étranges sur l'ambassade
américaine. Il doit y en avoir sur
d'autres ambassades d'ailleurs et qui le
savaiit. Bon, il se trouve que
l'ambassade américaine est à côté de
l'Élysée, c'est un peu plus gênant que
d'autres ambassades un peu plus loin,
mais enfin vous avez un centre russe
culturel russe qui était qui est juste à
côté des bâtiments de logement de
l'Élysée dont il y avait monsieur Benala
qui habitait là pendant un petit moment.
Donc bon, moi si vous voulez je serai
j'aurai des responsabilités dans mon
pays. Je n'autoriserai pas la Russie ou
notre pays soit hostile mais soit juste
un pays puissant. potentiellement ou
réellement à s'installer euh à être
souverain sur un petit territoire à côté
des logements du personnel de l'Élysé.
Bon bref, mais les espionnages grâce à
Wikileak de mémoire de la NS
Edward Snowden.
Edward Snowden. Et bon euh tout ça est
public,
il y a pas besoin comment c'est pas des
enfin il y a des révélations qui ont été
faites mais pas les révélations de
Wikipédia de Wikipédia de Wikileak
pardon. C'était il y a 2014 2015
peut-être. Oui à peu près ça. Bon
monsieur Hollande a été espionné. On
sait que ben dans le passé au passage
Shi espionné. Enfin SarkoZi
quelles conséquences ont été tirées même
dans le débat public de ça à rien du
tout.
Vous avez quoi comme téléphone ? Quelle
marque ?
Ben moi j'ai en pleine conscience j'ai
Apple. Voilà.
Vous avez fait auditer votre téléphone
s'il y avait pas un Pegasus ou euh
Non, j'ai pas fait audité. Je dire de
toute façon c'est mort puisque de toute
façon comment dire moi je suis à
l'ambassade des États-Unis, il faut
laisser son téléphone. Donc voilà. Donc
de toute façon, ça sert à rien. Je vais
vous dire moi mon échelon avec les peu
de moyens financiers, ça sert à rien.
Bon si si ça les intéresse mais ou
d'autres mais je fais juste attention à
ce que je dis. Voilà je vous dire en
fait la première quand vous avez des
moyens évidemment et que vous avez pas
le choix de dire des choses importantes
comme le président de la République euh
euh bon bah vous prenez des vous qui
c'est lui le problème qui a un téléphone
ordinaire je crois. Bon euh là c'est un
problème. Euh bon moi je surveille, je
fais juste attention euh à ce que je
dis, à quel moment je le dis et à qui
voilà. Mais ça c'est une faisiez à
l'ambassade américaine,
vous avez un entretien non pas avec
l'ambassadeur mais avec un de ses
représentants mais ça j'ai eu des j'en
ai eu plusieurs avec des représentants
mais américains mais c'est normal parce
qu'il faut discuter avec la première
puissance du monde et qu'on le veuille
ou non un pays qui assure une part
considérable de notre protection géné
avec quelle autre puissance
euh à part les États ?
Non non mais s'il me proposit Non mais
c'est pas du mépris parce que s'il me
proposait moi je rencontre tout le monde
enfin tout le monde dans le cadre de de
démocratie mais mais j'ai rencontré le
Japon
l'Inde, j'en ai pas vu beaucoup.
Revenons, revenons à vos autres
commissions.
Oui mais donc juste excusez-moi, je
finis donc sur le fait que vous avez dit
donc on parlait de
du constat. Voilà. Donc la souveraineté
agricole, la France qui a longtemps été
en dépendance sur son alimentation grâce
à la politique de du Conseil national de
la Résistance et de Gaulle était devenue
une puissance souveraine en agriculture.
Les gens pensent que ça a toujours été
le cas parce que on a l'image d'une
France toujours avec des beaux paysages,
des paysans sympathiques, la 3è
République glorieuse où on avait des
paysans effectivement qui faisaient ce
qu'il pouvaient. Mais non, on avait une
agriculture qui était un peu en retard,
qui avait du mal à nourrir le pays. Donc
c'était pas du tout un acquis d'avoir
une France souveraine alimentairement.
On a réussi à le faire. Maintenant, nous
sommes dépendants. Nous sommes
dépendants de nos importations. Alors,
pas forcément sur le blé, mais enfin sur
comment dire les fruits et légumes, sur
une part considérable de la viande
et tous les produits de la mer. Et en
fait, vous enlevez les vins spiritueux
et on a vu que ça peut vite partir quand
on voit ce que fait monsieur Trump. euh
une fois plus qu' soit-disant éternel ne
l'est pas euh et ben en fait nous sommes
en déficit commercial euh sur
l'alimentation, la politique énergétique
pareil. Pourquoi est-ce que la France
fait le programme nucléaire ? C'est pas
parce qu'on a que des génies nucléaires.
Les Italiens par exemple ont aussi des
génies nucléaires et ils ont pas du tout
fait euh cette même logique. C'est que
le général de Gaulle et d'autres ont
décidé dit "Bon, la France n'a pas de
pétrole. Alors, c'est une blague. La
France a pas de pétrole, a des idées.
C'est devenu un même. C'est devenu une
blague. Mais c'est pas une blague.
C'était une politique.
Un moment, il y a un entretien assez
connu du général de Gaul, je crois, avec
Nixon où Nixon dit oui, bon alors Nixon
est bien le général de Gaulle, mais
enfin, il lui dit "Bon, pourquoi la
France est toujours mauvaise humeur à
vouloir absolument être indépendante ?"
Et dit "Mais vous savez, si les
États-Unis n'avaient pas de pétrole, pas
de charbon euh et n'avait pas un océan
avec l'Allemagne, peut-être aussi que
vous auriez fait quelques révolutions et
que vous seriez de mauvaise humeur."
Voilà. Bon, donc le général de Gaulle a
tiré de la réalité, à savoir que la
France était avait était pauvre en
ressources naturelle
qu'il fallait créer notre propre
ressource naturelle, c'est-à-dire une
ressource venue du génie humain qui est
le nucléaire. Et on en revient à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure. Donc le
pourquoi est-ce qui mène cette politique
? C'est que il ne veut plus dépendre du
pétrole. À force, à partir du moment où
on rond, on rend l'Algérie, on rend sa
sa sa liberté, pardon, sa son
indépendance, excusez-moi, à l'Algérie
et qu'on ne veut pas avoir un fil à la
pâte trop avec ce pays-là, qu'on ne veut
pas avoir un fil à la pâte avec d'autres
pays, donc on fait le programme
nucléaire. Voilà. Bon, c'est en fait
c'est pas juste les gens confondent
toujours le phénomène avec la cause. Ce
n'est pas parce que le nucléaire en
France n'est pas fort parce qu'on juste
on a un un stock de centrale nucléaire
qui se serait tombé du ciel. C'était une
volonté stratégique de De Gaul et
d'ailleurs contre les essentiellement à
l'époque d'ailleurs contre les
Américains qui auraient été ravi d'avoir
que que comment dire la France s'intègre
parfaitement à l'atlantisme militaire et
économique. Alors on est intégré mais
eux ils voulaient une intégration plus
forte. D'ailleurs, qu'est-ce qu'on voit
là dans l'accord avec Trump sur les
commerces ?
C'est pas juste. Il veut pas
spécialement nous vendre du chewing-gum
ou des voitures américaines
et des banilons.
Des banilons, voilà. Pour reprendre ce
qu'on donne à l'époque de de la
libération. Trop sympathique en
l'occurrence de ces anecdotes là. Mais
c'est l'énergie. C'est l'énergie. Il
veut nous vendre son pétrole de chiste.
Il veut nous vendre son gaz de chiste.
Paf et créer le fil à la pâte. Pourquoi
? Parce qu'une fois que vous avez des
réseaux d'approvisionnement énergétique,
vous êtes dépendant. Voilà, je suis vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure, vous avez
comparé calories énergétiques, calories
alimentaires. Alors ça peut pas être
bizarre aux gens, on va pas bouffer du
pétrole.
Mais voilà, mais si on bouffe du
pétrole, voilà, il n'y a pas, vous
n'avez pas d'agriculture si vous avez
pas des tracteurs avec du pétrole, des
engrais avec du gaz. Voilà. Bon, il y a
pas le le l'énergie et depuis que je
déteste de banalités mais en
l'occurrence c'est vrai. Depuis que
l'homme a découvert le feu et même la
chasse, et ben l'énergie c'est la vie.
Les autres commissions c'était quoi ?
Après il y a eu la souveraineté
industrielle et comment réindustrialiser
mené par Alexandre Loué. Donc là, on a
pu aller au bout de des auditions. On a
rendu un rapport avec, je crois, plus de
100 propositions
très concrètes sur comment faire avec
assez consensuel d'ailleurs sur comment
réindustrialiser et d'ailleurs monsieur
Montebourg qui une fois plus n'est pas
du tout Rassemblée national et et même
est un adversaire politique euh comment
dire même si on peut se retrouver sur
des sur des sur des valeurs parce que on
aime la France tous ensemble, je pense
on n'est pas si nombreux. Euh bon ben en
fait ce programme il est clé sur table
mais il y a pas de révolution dedans.
Préconisation c'était quoi ? Il y en a
120 mais enfin essentiellementah
essentiellement c'est aligné comment
dire une fiscalité de production des
barrières commerciales et douanières
intelligente on choisit les marchés
qu'on veut attaquer les marchés sur
lesquels on se défend une formation
adaptée à cette ambition de reproduire
une démétropolisation
où on choisit des territoires où on dit
là on va construire telle filière là on
va construire telle filière un effort
considérable dans la recherche faut
passer comme la Corée ou Israël ou la
Corée à 4 5 % de de ref cherche dans le
PIB euh réserver les marchés publics. Je
l'ai dit, je vous dire, il y a rien de
révolutionnaire là-dedans. D'ailleurs,
sur les beaucoup de journalistes veulent
toujours une mesure. Alors oui, vous
voulez campagne électorale, vous voulez
réindustrialiser la France, quelle
mesure ? Mais ça existe pas ça. Il y a
pas une mesure pour industrialiser la
France. Il y a un programme assez pas
ennuyeux mais un peu roboratif hein.
Ari.
Aride exactement pour industrialiser la
France. Il y a rien de
traversé du désert ce qui nous attend
là. Mais on est dans le désert.
Moi, j'ai l'impression quand j'écoute
monsieur Berou et tout que que le
dromadaire découvre qu'il a bouffé ses
boss quoi. Bon bah, on est dans le
désert, on a bouffé nos réserves et il y
a encore pas mal à faire quoi. Donc moi,
je suis un peu un peu stupéfait. Vous en
avez parlé pour les problèmes de
souveraineté. Ça veut dire la France a 9
% de son PIB en valeur industrielle
manufacturée. C'est-à-dire vous enlevez
les conneries, tous les parasites qui
tournent autour de l'industrie. En fait
dans des gens qui produisent de la
richesse industrielle, on est 9 plutôt
8. Si vraiment on enlève tout ceux qui
ont qui sont pas des des ouvriers, enfin
qui ne produisent pas de valeur
industrielle. On est au niveau de la
Grèce euh qui je pense dans
l'inconscient français n'est pas une
puissance industrielle. C'était même le
contrexemple absolu. Bon, le pauvre
grec, ils avaient rien ils avaient rien
fait pour mériter ça non plus. Le le on
est dans cette situationlà.
Et donc pareil, un des problèmes tout bê
quand je vous disais, les hommes et les
femmes politiques qui ont dirigé ce pays
s'en foutent. Eux ce qu'ils veulent un
plan de com. Je m'explique dans ce
rapport mais aussi dans le rapport je
crois de monsieur Louani pareil qui qui
vient du socialisme donc qui est pas du
tout libre à l'Assemblée nationale à qui
ils avaient confié le rapport sur la
réindustrialisation de la France.
Qu'est-ce qu'il dit comme premier
problème ? dit justement les politiques
publiques sont obsédées par des mesures
glamour, des grands plans, des machins
qui permettent de tenir BFM ces news
pendant la journée et puis après il se
passe rien. Qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par là ? C'est les grands programmes.
Alors on va faire un très grand
programme sur l'hydrogène, un très grand
programme sur la pompe à chaleur. Que
des grands programmes qui permettent de
des batteries. Alors les batteries nous
les usines de batterie, on nous les a
vendu matin, midi et soir 200 fois. Bon
euh euh je pense d'y avoir 30 discours
de Macron où la réindustrialisation
c'est l'ouverture d'usine de batterie.
J'ai rien contre le fait de faire des
batteries. On peut faire des batteries,
il y a une technologie à saisir, il y a
pas de problème. Mais qu'est-ce que
c'est des grands programmes pour ouvrir
un gros ruban avec un gros ciseau. Mais
c'est pas ça la politique de
réindustrialisation. Mais ce que dit le
rapport louc comme d'autres, c'est le
problème c'est les intermédiaires, c'est
le réseau de TPE, PME, d'entreprises
intermédiaires, ceux qui ont des
compétences parce que ces grands
projets, ces grandes usines ne font
qu'assembler ou consolider tout un tas
de compétences qui soit autour dans les
PME et les TPE, les PME, les ETI et les
compétences des ter des territoires
organisées entre eux. Et donc si vous
êtes obsédé uniquement par le grand
projet, paradoxalement vous en venez
même à écraser, à assécher toutes tous
les intermédiaires qui vous permettent
de réindustrialiser la France. Il y a
pas d'industrialisation par le haut. Il
peut y avoir une planification par le
haut. Mais la planification, c'est pas
je crée un grand projet qui va
ruisseler, comme disait l'autre Macron,
euh sur le territoire. C'est l'inverse.
C'est on en revient à la démocratie, je
suis désolé hein, tout est dans tout.
C'est par la base que l'industrie se
fait, que la décision se prend, que les
forces humaines se mettent en place,
s'organisent et font des produits, font
des compétences, ont des savoir-faires
qui à la fin vous permet de porter un
grand projet. Mais une centrale
nucléaire, c'est
évidemment une compétence
unique, mais c'est des robinets, la
tuyauterie, savoir souder s retrouv ça
plus souder. Voilà. Alors, c'est pas des
soudures, c'est pas euh euh c'est pas
moi, vous euh au collège qu'on faisait
des soudures pour apprendre en cours de
technologie. C'est des soudures de très
haut niveau évidemment, on appelle ça
soudure mais c'est chose. Bon, mais
c'est l'accumulation de tout ça. Mais on
en revient en fait comme les gens, ces
gens qui prennent ces décisions ou qui
font leur conférence de presse, n'ont
que mépris
pour la base entre guillemets, donc que
mépris pour les compétences manuelles,
donc on mépris en fait
pour l'apprentissage, pour tout ça, on
en revient là. Moi, je me souviens à un
moment l'ancien directeur de Véolial,
donc j'ai oublié le nom, c'était il y a
10 ans, euh a été en charge de
l'apprentissage, enfin du développement
de l'apprentissage pour la deuxè fois en
France et puis fait une interview, je
crois, sur France Inter, il dit "Ah,
vous est-ce que vos enfants sont
apprentis ?" Ah bah non. Alors, vous
aviez tout était là-dedans. Voilà, une
fois plus. Bon, voilà, Marine Le Pen
valorise l'apprentissage. Il se trouve,
elle le dit souvent, c'est pas une
révélation, que son fils a été apprenti
cheudronier. Voilà. Donc vous avez des
dirigeants politiques qui sont cohérents
dans leur vie et et dans la
représentation symbolique de ce qu'ils
disent aux Français qui sont cohérents
disant bah moi j'ai mon fils qui était
qui a fait un apprentissage et c'est une
fierté et rien d'autre. Et puis vous
avez des gens qui disent entre
guillemets euh à la population, bah vous
c'est vous c'est ça et puis nous c'est
ça. Voilà. Bon, tout est là-dedans. Mais
fois plus c'est pas de la confusion dans
mon esprit, c'est très clair. Tout est
je pas dire je suis marxiste mais la
représentation de classe
en France a un rôle considérable et
c'est un poison. C'est là où je suis pas
marxiste. C'est que c'est un poison pour
la cohésion nationale et les politiques
qui sont menées.
Donc il y a quand même des élus qui
bossent du côté des communistes. Ils ont
fait un très bon rapport sur l'énergie.
G
ah non l'énergie vous parliez des des
entreprises pardon
aussi. Euh donc il y a quand même des
gens qui bossent. Ceux qui s'en foutent,
comme vous le décrivez,
c'est qu'il s'en foutent parce que c'est
des directeurs de BD, c'est des
présidents de BDE, parce que c'est des
présidents de com d'événementiel,
parce qu'ils ont un agenda politique où
c'est une forfaiture et c'est une
ingérence étrangère à ce niveau-là parce
que tout le monde comprend en France que
l'indépendance alimentaire,
on a fait quelques révolutions quand il
y avait plus rien dans les gamelles et
y avait presque plus rien dans bon dans
les gardes mangé
et oui bah les gilets jaunes c'est la
dernière forme révolutionnaire qu'on a
eu hein.
Donc votre dernière commission
avec la réponse violente qu'il a eu.
Votre dernière commission c'était quoi ?
Bah la dernière c'était sur la
souveraineté industrielle
pas les ingérences étrangères.
Non ça celle que j'ai présidé c'était la
première.
D'accord.
Ou la deuxième ? La deuxième
comment ça s'est passé cette les
auditions pour cette affaire là ?
Bah c'était assez intéressant. On a
suivi de temps en temps, on a bien
rigolé.
Oui, bah ça j'imagine.
Et on a bien rigolé. Pourquoi ? parce
que on se demande si la DGSI, la DGSE
avait fait le pédigré des gars ou des
nanas que vous avez pu auditionner
parce que nous nous on se fait sentir on
se fait sentir par les services. Ils
nous connaissent bien, ils nous sentent
de très près parce que ils nous trouvent
dans des endroits où on n'est pas censé
être mais comme on a dit coup d'avance
parce que on voit les choses avant eux,
on se retrouve à à être prépositionné
sur le le les chiqu avant eux pour
sentir l'air du temps. Comment ça s'est
passé les auditions de tout ça ? Vous
aviez fait un petit peu vous vous aviez
pas demandé au service de vous fournir
le pays des gens que vous auditionniez
ou
on a rien à demander au services demande
rien. On a rien à
ils ont alerté parce que bah monsieur
machin travaille par les anglais
monsieur machin travaille par ça
n'existe. Je vous dis de fois plus nous
avons pas d'information descendante
de l'État. Enfin, par exemple,
excusez-moi, il y a vous avez des
parlementaires comme monsieur
l'ex-parlementaire Buntan, député de
Paris euh que j'ai auditionné et il y a
une enquête en cours. Bon, visiblement
je
sur quoi ?
Bah sur ses liens avec le Parti
communiste chinois via la diaspora
chinoise. Il était je crois d'origine
cambodgienne, sa famille d'origine
cambodgienne. Bon bref, des histoires
très anciennes. Bon et puis vous avez
ensuite pour le coup le à l'époque il a
déjà
avéré ou pas avéré par exemption
d'innocent si
Ah ben oui, j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'il y
avait une enquête en cours mais voilà là
on nous a dit fait savoir bon. Comme par
hasard, c'était sur un cas qui avait pas
beaucoup d' enfin comment dire, c'est
pas ça qui va changer le destin de la
France. Bon euh euh Non, mais il y a pas
de ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
hein, il y a jamais très rarement
d'information descendantes euh qui
viennent aux députés. Les seuls députés
qui ont un peu d'information
descendantes sur le renseignement, c'est
ceux qui sont la délégation
parlementaire pour le renseignement.
Donc de mémoire, ils sont quatre, ils
doivent être quatre députés, quatre
sénateurs, mais j'ai pas envie de me
tromper, mais ça doit être à peu près
ça. Euh et eux, ils sont astreins et et
c'est normal d'ailleurs, enfin c'est à
la fois normal et anormal.
Astrein ou habilité ? Ils sont habilités
et donc parce qu'ils sont habilités
astreints à une confidentialité
parfaite. Et c'est vrai par exemple
Caroline Colombier qui siège pour le
Rassembl national député national qui
siège à cette délégation euh depuis 3
ans ne m'a jamais donné un mot parce
qu'elle n'a pas le droit de faire et que
d'ailleurs je lui rien demandé
d'ailleurs. Bon euh mais paradoxalement
donc les gens les députés ou les
sénateurs qui ont des informations, ils
peuvent pas en parler. Mais ça à la
limite moi ça me choque pas mais dans
cette sinon il y a plus de raison d'état
mais dans cette dans cette comment dire
dans cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire je vois à peu près des
profils dont vous parlez qui ont souvent
pignon sur rue de médias ou qui sont à
la tête de cercle de réflexion de cercle
de pensée dont personne ne se demande
jamais comment ils sont financés. le euh
le le je veux dire ça c'est l'écume des
vagues. Le but de cette commission
c'était de renseigner et de
d'auditionner sous serment des gens qui
sont des vrais serviteurs de l'État qui
ont des vraies responsabilités. Donc les
deux direct qui étaient sous étaient
sous h clos
écrites sont publiques et c'est
d'ailleurs un peu le coup de Trafalgar
parce que tout le monde s'est foutu de
ma gueule. Dit oui ce pauvre Tangui qui
l'abruti quel con. Il s'est fait avoir
par les Macronis dans la commission sur
les ingérences. Euh ma rapporteur
Constance Legripe euh a fait un rapport
épouvantable sur le RN, mais je savais
que euh les Macronistes allaient faire
un rapport épouvantable sur le RN.
Est-ce que vous avez été financé par les
les ruches ?
Pas été financé du tout. Tout ça est un
mensonge.
Ah alors expliquez juste fini pourquoi
moi ce que je voulais c'était publier
euh parce que je savais que ce serait
clos. Je voulais publier les
compte-rendus de l'audition de la DGSE,
de la DGSI, de Trackf, de la chat TVP,
bref, de toutes les autorités qui eux
ont quelque chose à dire sous serment et
qui s'il mentait poserait quand même un
vrai problème. Donc c'est c'est ça que
je voulais. Or, je ne pouvais publier
les rapports écrits que si j'étais
président et pas rapporteur. Voilà. et
le rapporteur et et donc si le président
Béit macroniste, il aurait pu couper le
sifflet euh à ses auditions. Donc en
fait, bon, moi je suis désolé pour la
petite histoire, c'est moi qui ai [__]
les macronistes et pas l'inverse.
Non, il faut pas utiliser ce vocabur
non mais j'en profite parce que je
pourrais jamais le dire ailleurs. Donc
et donc
et on remercie notre communauté de nous
financer. C'est grâce à à ça qu'on est
obligé euh de de vous reprendre quand
vous dites des grosses fierretés. Alors
n'hésitez pas à nous financer sur Tipi.
J'espère bien. Attention hein, vous
allez faire pénitence dans pas très
longtemps.
J'ai beaucoup de pénitence à faire. Il
faudra faudra prenne et revenons. Alors
euh donc vous avez pas été financé par
les Russes ? Vous avez été financé par
les Russes ou pas ? C'est
façon c'est très simple.
Euh je faire appel évidemment à
l'intelligence collective. Si Marine Le
Pen avait été financé par les Russes, le
président de la République le saurait et
donc lors de son débat euh face à elle,
il aurait pas fait des accusations, il
aurait dit des choses à la France. Il
n'a rien dit à la France. Et s'il ose
espérer que si le premier le le le
président de la République ou d'autres
savait su enfin savait avait une
parfaite connaissance que le principal
parti d'opposition, le Rassemblement
national qui peut avoir le pouvoir été
financé par une puissance non seulement
étrangère mais non seulement hostile
mais en l'occurrence en guerre contre un
pays européen et ayant comment dire
franchi toutes les règles du droit
international. Je pense que les Français
le seraient pas des petites accusations
via médiia part ou machin mais que il y
aurait un vrai problème d'état. Il n'y a
pas de problème d'état puisqu'il n'y a
pas de financement euh par la Russie du
Rassemblement national.
Ouais, mais ils ont peut-être fait un
billard à trois bandes en passant par
une banque tchèque. Mais
c'est pas un billard à trois bandes tout
ça. C'est Mia Part qui le sort. Le
Rassemble national a fait un prêt qui
lui a coûté extrêmement cher. Euh là je
je sais plus, je peux pas vous dire les
montants. J'ai pas je déteste dire des
bêtises.
Quel taux ?
Ah ben le taux était là pour le coup
sous serment. Le président de la
commission des comptes de la SN CCFP, la
Commission nationale des comptes de
campagne du financement de la vie
politique a dit par souserment que le
taux du prêt russe entre guillemets
était bien supérieur au taux de marché
et au taux dont on aurait bénéficié en
France. Donc c'est pas une faveur,
c'était un coût de ce prêt euh étranger.
Et par ailleurs, ce prêt a été validé
par Trackfin pareil sous serment, a été
validé euh par toutes les autorités à
l'époque. Et en fait, de toute façon,
vous savez, je vais vous dire dans
l'introduction parce que j'ai fait euh
j'ai fait une petite méchanceté à ma
rapporteur Macronis, j'ai fait le plus
gros avant-propos, un des plus gros
avant-propos de l'histoire des rapports
parlementaires et je la remercie
d'ailleurs. Merci Constance de ne pas
l'avoir mis en annexe et l'avoir laissé
en introduction. Merci.
Euh dans cet avant-propos, euh
j'explique le cas mélanc parle même pas
que du RN. Je suis un adversaire total.
Il est pas là pour se défendre
Jean-Luc mais là c'est gentil, vous
allez voir. Il est régulièrement invité,
il avait été accusé quand il était un
peu puissant puis quand il dérangeait
François Hollande d'être un agent du
Venezuela. Voilà, il avait même inventé
la boîte à meu Venezuela. Je sais pas si
vous souvenez de cette anecdote. Voilà,
il se moquait effectivement. En fait la
boîte à me
Venezuela, quand ça remonte quand ça
remonte quand le comment dit les
insoumis étaient enfin à l'époque
c'était le parti de gauche était
électoralement puissant ou capable de
gêner la gauche. Ah
ils sont toujours puissants hein.
Oui oui mais à l'époque Oui mais à
l'époque ça allait déranger. C'est ça le
contexte c'est qu'à l'époque il venaient
déranger le pouvoir en place à savoir
Hollande. Aujourd'hui ils sont alliés
donc il dérange plus. Donc il y a plus
Venezuela c'est fini pas. Ah si comme
par hasard là depuis qu'ils sont
refachés maintenant s'ils sont avec la
la Chine. Alors que bon Mélanchon a déjà
dit des choses épouvantables sur le
Tibet. Euh il y a 20 ans, tout ça est
archivé sur internet une émission avec
monsieur Tadaï où il expliquait que
l'invasion du Tibet était parfaitement
normale. Bon bref, donc c'est pas
nouveau, ça que je veux dire. Mais ça
ressort à des moments où c'est pas une
vérité euh pour informer les lecteurs de
son libre choix. C'est pour créer de la
confusion, de la désinformation pour
[__] la trouille aux gens. Et
d'ailleurs, vous pouvez tout à mon avis
si quelqu'un mais on m'entend quelqu'un
qui a la capacité technique de le faire
de faire un algorithme de regarder la
récurrence euh des attaques sur les
ingérences soit-disant imaginaires
russes ou chinoises ou n'importe quoi ou
Venezuela par rapport
Oui. Alors là pour le coup, c'est
rarement pendant les élections comme par
hasard le le comment dire le le je pense
qu'il y a des petites pointes des petits
pics de de d'accusation russe
régulièrement. Voilà.
Militarisation de l'information, on va
en parler, je vous laisse terminer. Oui,
par exemple récemment, il y a encore eu,
il y avait eu encore un documentaire du
service public où je suis allé me
confronter à eux sur bah les ingérences
russes. Je vais vous dire les documents
qui soit-disant sont censés influencer
le débat politique français sont
tellement caricaturaux, grotesque un peu
à la soviétique d'ailleurs. C'est
vraiment du gros gros gros rouge qui
tâche sans mauvais jeune.
Je peux me couper une seconde ?
Oui.
Bah, il y a quand même des ingérences
russes.
Oui. Mais fonctionne pas en France. Ce
qui est très intéressant pour le coup
dans les auditions de la commission
d'ingérance et ceux qui veulent aller
lire les témoignages et les sous
serments euh euh notamment de Virginum.
Donc Viginum est une jeune une
commission, une instance, une agence, je
sais plus quel est son statut. Enfin, ce
sont des gens euh des fonctionnaires euh
qui sont qui surveillent justement les
attaques numériques et les ingérences
numériques pendant les élections qui
font un rapport au conseil
constitutionnel et le pendant les
élections, au termes des élections
pardon. Et le conseil constitutionnel
juge par rapport aux informations de
Viginum s'il y a eu ingérence électorale
ou pas pendant les élections. Et Viginum
a dit il y a il y a eu des tentatives
d'ingérence russe mais n'ont aucune
efficacité en France. Et en faitinou,
ils sont peut-être aussi mauvais. Il ils
voient rien. Mais vous voyez les trucs,
on vous voyez les trucs passés.
D'ailleurs, ça a été ça a été dit dans
le débat public que quand les Russes ont
tenté via finalement des moldaves, je ne
sais plus, ont tenté d'influencer le
débat politique en en appuyant sur
l'antisémitisme qui revient,
voilà, les étoiles bleues. Donc là,
c'était un peu bizarre que ce soit des
étoiles bleues pour appuyer là-dessus en
France en tout cas.
Euh et ben finalement, ça a été su et
donc les électeurs l'ont su. Donc bon,
ce sont des machinations qui sont
déjoues et d'ailleurs donc
cercueil en bas de la tour Effel aussi.
Oui, voilà. Enfin, je suis pas sûr que
les électeurs de la Somme étaient
sensible au fait qu'il y a des cercueils
sous la tour échelle. Mais et là
récemment la campagne euh qu'il a eu sur
différentes capitales européennes y
compris Paris avec des affiches avec la
police euh soviétique sur remercier le
soldat russe qui vous a libéré du
nazisme il y a 80 ans.
Moi j'ai même pas vu ça peut-être mais
enfin bon j'ai pas vu pour en
l'occurrence le rôle de l'armée
soviétique c'est pas l'armée de monsieur
Poutine. une réalité historique, faut
quand même pas oublier les dizaines de
milliers millions de morts de de russes
qui n'ont rien à voir avec Staline qui
sont des honnêtes gens qui ont été
envoyé au front et heureusement qu'ils
étaient là pour faire un deuxième front.
Enfin, d'ailleurs c'était le premier et
c'est le front ouest occident ouest
européen mais voilà mais donc ils font
un bilan et ils disent c'est ça qui est
quand même qui est stupéfiant dire il y
a pas de complot si les gens vont à
l'info ils l'ont. Il y a Virginou dit,
il n'y a pas d'ingérence électorale
susceptible de changer les élections. Et
en fait ce que disent ce qu'il disent
dans ces auditions, ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est qu'ils disent la
démocratie française fonctionne
robuste.
Elle fonctionne les gens déjà la
première protection c'est le l'éducation
et l'intelligence des gens. Alors c'est
sûr que ça déplaît au macroniste, mais
c'est la première protection d'une
démocratie. Deuxièmement, les médias
sont suffisamment pluralistes, soit les
médias officiels, soit les médias
alternatifs pour faire vivre le départ.
Et et puis il y a la confrontation tout
simplement, c'est que donc il y a des
débats politiques et on se confronte et
et et tout ça fonctionne très bien en
fait. Donc les ingérences russes
électoral malheureusement il fonctionne
un peu dans certains régimes africains
où justement il y a pas ces médias
comment dire qu' un peu pignon sur eux.
Il y a pas cette qualité de débat
électoral, il y a pas un niveau
d'éducation forcément suffisant qui
permet aux gens d'avoir les les moyens
de la liberté. Voilà. Quel pays quel
pays qui nous fait de l'ingérence en
France,
que ce soit électoralement parlant ou
industriellement parlant, quels sont nos
je vais dire nos ennemis ?
Bah la la Russie et la Chine essaie de
faire de l'ingérance mais ça fonctionne
pas parce que elles sont rejetées. C'est
comme une balle qui rebondit sur la
société française
qui s'y prennent mal. Oui, mais
d'ailleurs c'est pas votre question est
est intéressante parce qu'en fait je
pense aussi que pour faire de
l'ingérence efficace, il faut être
culturellement lié
et culturellement proche. Et donc, mais
vous voyez, moi je vois sur TikTok
parfois le régime russe qui fait des
vidéos, qui essaie d'imiter les vidéos
américaines pour rendre sympathique le
régime russe. C'est tellement gros,
enfin une fois plus, c'est tellement
caricatural. C'est une blonde, enfin on
dirait une agent du KGB dans dans dans
James Bond. Enfin bon, c'est tellement
caricatural en fait que enf tu vois ça
sont brunes en général dans le je
bah là elle est blonde. Voilà, je bon
euh peut-être une brune que j'ai pas vu
et euh je suis parfois insensible et et
euh voilà. Ben bon ça marche pas quoi.
Voilà. Bon, je pense que si la Chine
fait, je sa pas vous avez vu le défilé
militaire à Pékin avec le reste du sud
global, c'est à la fois impressionnant.
Évidemment, il faut en tenir compte.
Mais il y a aussi un côté décalé lié au
fait que c'est pas
on n'était pas représenté, on n'a pas
été invité. Le général de Gaulle avait
reconnu la la chou
Oui, bien sûr. Oui.
Pourquoi on n pas on n pas été invité ?
On a on est pas allé.
Je sais pas, j'ai j'ai pas cette
information. Je sais pas est-ce qu'on a
ignoré, pas été invité. J'ai vu qu'il y
avait la Slovaquie et la Hongrie, mais
bon, est-ce que est-ce que on a été
invité ? Est-ce qu'on y pas allé ? Je ne
sais pas
quand on voit des des des élus recevoir
des tapis, recevoir des des voyages,
recevoir des machins,
il y a des enquêtes,
il y a il y a beaucoup de transparence
quand même aujourd'hui dans ce que
reçoivent les élus. Mais je vais vous
dire de toute façon,
est-ce qu'on a essayé de vous acheter ?
Non,
même pas un petit tamponnage de derrière
les fagot.
J'ai eu un vieux soupçon il y a très
longtemps sur euh un russe qui m'avait
lourdement dragué et qui sortait un peu
nulle part qui avait une histoire
personnelle un peu louche. Euh voilà. En
2014-215.
Vous l'avez péchaud ?
Non.
Lui vous a péchaud ?
Non. Ma paranoï naturelle m'a protégé.
Voilà. Mais mais en même temps si trouve
c'est de la paranoï. Et ce pauvre garçon
n'avait rien de méchant le pauvre.
Voilà. J'en sais rien. Voà. Mais si vous
me demandez, j'essaie de ne pas mentir.
Voilà. Une fois cette chose m traversé
par l'esprit. Mais sinon
2015.
Ouais. Là, vous prenez un preuve pour
point. C'est pas non plus un événement
central dans ma vie. Mais si je suis
honnête, voilà, j'ai eu ce petit doute
un jour là-dessus. Voilà. Bon, encore ça
pas bien loin. Mais
doute ma [__] quoi.
C'est vous qui avez fait le jeune mot.
Mais le
Vous êtes habité un peu.
Comment
vous êtes habité un peu ?
C'est-à-dire
par le doute.
Ah bah toujours. Ben j'espère. Alors si
pareil on en revient, si un jour je le
suis plus euh faut me piquer. Bon le
Vous êtes pour l'euthanasie ?
J'ai voté pour. Oui.
Bon allez continuez.
Voilà. Mais j'avais dit que j'avais
votre épou, donc j'ai pris personne par
surprise. Euh,
arrêtez les jeux de mots,
promis.
Enfin, promis, j'aime pas faire des
promesses que je suis pas sûr de tenir.
Le le
Vous appelez pas Charles Pasquois, c'est
ça ?
Ah ben j'aime beaucoup Charles ça.
Charles Pasquois c'est Je sais qu'il est
de bon chez les souverainistes de dire
qu'on est avant tout guiniste, quel est
le gentil et pas Charles qui est vu
comme le méchant mais moi mon vrai
mentor c'est le méchant. Je suis désolé.
Ce était bien, on ouvre une parenthèse,
on fait des digressions. Ce il était
bien non ?
Il était très très bien. Mais j'ai
préféré Charles parce quoi ? Mais
préférence personnelle pourquoi ? parce
que les Corse
déjà, j'aime bien, j'aime bien
effectivement la le peuple corse mais
mais le le
grand résistant engagé très jeune au
période de sa vie et puis assumant,
il a fait quelques trucs hein.
Oui, d'accord. Mais mais ça je vais vous
dire moi, je vais vous dire comment dire
Charles Pasquais assumait aussi qu'on ne
défend pas l'intérêt national en étant
un ange. Voilà. Et le général de Gaulle
n'était pas un ange.
Et il y a des gens qui sont l'enfer est
pas de bonnes intentions et moi si je
peux me permettre, je pense que ceux qui
choisissent des anges choisissent le
diable.
C'était quoi votre première votre
question avant tout ça ?
Le diable était peut-être un ange déchu.
C'est ça ?
Bah le diable est toujours un ange
déchu. Ouais. Mais vous avez la solution
dans votre propre référence. Mais si les
gens, je parlais tout à l'heure des
catholiques qui sont qui devraient
pratiquants qui revendiquent, il
devraient parfois fuser dans leur dans
leurs sources pour savoir le vrai. En
tout cas essayer de le trouver.
Revenons un petit peu aux ingérences.
Quelles sont les puissances ? Quels sont
nos ennemis ?
Mais le plus facile de faire de
l'ingérance, c'est pas nos ennemis.
C'est pas nos ennemis. Bah si vous
commencez à vouloir faire des
crocheptes, que vous êtes le voisin de
la France, vous faites des crocheptes
sur son système industriel et qui finit,
ça va vider les frigos des Français. K
vous connaissez le proverbe de guerre
économique ?
Oui. Mais quand il choses différent,
c'est quoi le proverbe de guerre
économique ?
Comment
c'est quoi le proverbe de guerre
économique ?
Ah le probe entendu le programme mais
j'ai pas
le proverbe c'est un chômeur coûte plus
cher qu'un mort.
Donc infiné infiné c'est les frigos des
français qui se vident. inf, c'est la
France qui est menacée parce que quand
il y a plus rien dans les frigos, ça
commence à se chauffer, à s'échauffer et
vous ouvrez le peuple français à toutes
tous les quatre vents de propagande ou
d'ingérence parce que un peuple qui a
faim est un peuple qui commence à à se
fâcher. Donc les gens ne perçoivent pas
les les mécanismes de guerre économique
comme les mécanismes de guerre. Je
t'envoie un petit obus sur la tête, il
est 4h du matin, tu perds tes gamins.
Non, là c'est beaucoup plus pernicieux.
Mais moi je pense que les gens l'ont
perçu parce que si vous voulez que vous
voyez le processus de
désindustrialisation,
les votes sur une fois plus l'Union
européenne, le rapport au libre échange,
moi je pense que le peuple
quels sont les ennemis ?
Mais je une fois plus voilà, j'ai
entendu ce que vous dites mais je pense
qu'ils sont pas ennemis. Voilà, ils sont
adversaires et adversaires parfois sans
scrupule mais c'est plus pour leur
intérêt propre que vouloir faire du mal
à la France volontairement. C'est ça que
je voulais dire. Le c'est ceux qui sont
le plus proche culturellement de nous.
Ce qui fait que c'est presque invisible,
c'est évidemment les États-Unis,
Rume-Uni. Oui, mais les les anglais, moi
je connais moins euh
mais les États-Unis essentiellement qui
ont une proximité culturelle qui fait
que c'est presque agréable d'avoir de
l'ingérance. C'est là où c'est dangereux
ou c'est où c'est même très difficile
pour nous. Moi-même j'aime bien
sous-culture américaine, série, les
films, la pop musique, le rap, enfin
tout ce que produit les États-Unis et
séduisant.
C'est quoi votre rappeur préféré
américain ?
Moi je préfère le pour le coup, je
préfère le rap français. Et moi je suis
resté 13 années 90. Je vous dire MC
Solar, je vous dire MC Solar. Je vous
dire MC Solar. Donc ça devit quand même
très ringard. Mais bon, moi je suis
restingard du tout.
Je pense que c'est qui vont nous
regarder.
Oui, je suis d'accord. Mais je pense que
effectivement il y a une maîtrise du
français. C'est-à-dire que pour moi le
rap c'est une forme de poésie. Donc
américain déjà je pense qu'on on en rate
beaucoup mais euh voilà. Mais bon, mais
moi en pop musique, je fais une
caricature hein. Moi j'aime toutes
toutes les pop stars les plus
commerciales et les plus grand public.
Je suis à fond au premier rang à
applaudir si je pouvais. Si j'avais le
temps, j'irai encore. Voilà. Donc
concentrez-vous, on s'en fout.
Voilà. Voilà. On s'en fout. Oui, mais
c'est pour dire voilà, j'ai pas c'est
mais je suis totalement là-dedans.
Voilà. Donc je suis pas en train de me
dire "Moi, je suis un saint qui vit dans
une un ermite qui vit dans une grotte."
Mais justement on avoir conscience,
voyez, je don des exemples. Par exemple,
quand vous faites parler les gens de la
justice française, comment fonctionne la
justice française ? vous pouvez faire le
test, ils vont vous décrire le système
judiciaire américain tellement ils ont
plus vu de de de séries ou de films
américains, ils vont dire ils objection
votre honneur. Ce qui n'existe pas par
exemple dans le dans le système
judiciaire euh français. Bon euh il y a
plein de de choses comme ça où les gens
vont croire que en fait on vit dans une
culture américaine et en fait c'est
presque impossible de lutter contre ça
parce que c'est enfin
ça fait partie des ingérences. Bah bien
sûr parce qu'en fait vous en fait il ça
perm dans les accords dans après guerre
léon Léon Bloom pour obtenir une aide
financière des États-Unis cette aide
financière est conditionnée à un certain
nombre de facilitations commerciales et
dans ces facilitations commerciales il y
a l'importation massive de films
américains. Certes, le film est en lui
même un outil commercial mais c'est
aussi un outil culturel. Et donc quand
vous avez une pénétration massive des
films américains dans l'après-guerre,
c'est aussi un narratif américain sur un
certain mode de vie. Qui est le gentil,
qui est le méchant dans l'histoire. Vous
aboutissez, je suis désolé, on en a
parlé tout à l'heure, vous aboutissez à
la fin où les gens de toute sincérité
pensent que les États-Unis ont eu un
sacrifice humain plus lourd que l'Union
soviétique pendant la guerre. Alors,
vous prenez, il y a un sondage de l'IPOP
parce que l'IPOP est un vie institut qui
demandait au Français à l'après-guerre
qui a fourni l'effort de guerre maximale
pour libérer l'Europe des nazis après la
guerre, je crois que c'était 60 ou 70 %
l'URSS, c'est la réalité historique. Et
maintenant, vous posez la question aux
gens avec il faut sauver le soldat Ryan
et et d'autres œuvres, ils ont inversé
le rapport. Non pas queévidemment les
Américains
les soldats américains n'aient pas donné
leur vie évidemment en éternellement
reconnaissant moi dans la Somme
évidemment Picardi deux fois première
seconde guerre mondiale éternellement
reconnaissant du sacrifice des soldats
américains. Mais il y a une réécriture
du narratif y compris évidemment par les
par les œuvres et les séries ce qui
d'ailleurs en soi n'est pas grave.
Vous avez connu des soldats
faut juste en avoir conscience.
Vous avez des connu des des soldats
américains de la deuxième guerre ?
Moi personnellement pas
un pilote de bombardier qui habitait à
Kibron. Moi, j'en ai connu un parce que
j'en ai connu un, c'était le mari de
d'une deun famille encore qui est
presque comme ma famille. Voilà. Bon
voilà. Ou
az connu l'autre côté du côté rouge ?
Non. Ma famille était il y a eu beaucoup
de résistants mais tous golistes. Et le
seul rapport qu'on a eu avec la
résistance communiste, c'est à la
libération quand les communistes ont
voulu liquider un certain nombre de de
de résistants qui étaient pas de bonne
obédience. Ça n'enlève rien à la
résistance communiste, mais ça donne un
petit point de vue. Donc
pas du tout.
Vous êtes pas du toutac. Ah non, je
comprends pas le concept.
C'est quoi le concept pour vous ?
Ben je comprends pas donc je sais pas je
je je comprends pas mais vraiment je on
m'a inv quand j'étais au lycée Henric,
on m'avait invité avec un ami à la
Grande Loge là à Rucad
18e.
Ouais oui oui je sais plus cad et le le
la mémoire que j'ai je me souviens d'un
portrait d'Abd Cader. C'est les
souvenirs qu'on a comme ça. Qu'est-ce
que je fous là quoi ? Donc je suis parti
le seul voilà je comprends pas le
concept. Même pas le folklore ?
Comment ?
Même pas le folklore ?
Non non. D'ailleurs, j'ai un ami pour la
petite histoire, j'avais un ami que j'ai
bergé un moment. J'avais un soupçon.
Enfin soupçon rien, ils font ce qu'ils
veulent, chacun fait ce qu'il veut. Et
je lui dis peut-être tu me fais pas ton
tablier et tout. Puis j'ai découvert 10
ans plus tard, je que c'est vrai qu'il
avait appelé qu'il avait dans sa valise
en tablier sans me dire. Voilà. Bon, en
soi, je m'en fiche complètement mais euh
ça m'a fait d'ailleurs, je me souviens
parce que bon bref, il y avait il y a
beaucoup d'anecdotes là-dessus mais je
je comprends pas le concept.
Revenons, revenons aux ingérences en
France. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On
sponsorise encore le cinéma français
pour résister à la pénétration.
Regardez, il y a un tout petit pays.
Quoi d'autre ?
Il y a un tout petit pays qui a à peu
près la même population que la France.
J'ai pas vu la superficie tiens, qui a
aucune ressource naturelle comme nous.
C'est la Corée du Sud. Bon, qui est dans
une position en plus beaucoup plus
compliquée que nous géographiquement.
Euh bah la Corée du Sud aujourd'hui
c'est un champion culturel
par la K-pop, par le cinéma, ils ont des
prix, des séries, y compris d'ailleurs
des séries où ils font un effet de judo
avec Netflix qui fait qu'une série
coréenne utilise une plateforme
américaine pour euh comment dire briller
euh briller dans le monde entier.
Voilà espèce non mais c'est vrai espèce
de bel judo. Bah moi je voy c'est le
Japon en l'occurrence mais les arts
martiaux asiatiques euh bon bref
retourne le truc. Bon les Américains
sont ce qu'ils veulent avant tout c'est
faire du fric comme tout le monde j'ai
envie de dire. Bon donc bon que la Corée
puisse se faire mousser au passage ça
les ça les dérange pas et tant mieux. Et
nous en France bah ce système de de
l'exception culturelle tout le monde
parle de l'exception culturelle mais
c'est aujourd'hui c'est un concept vide.
C'est c'est quel est le message ou les
messages parce qu'on n'est pas
heureusement pas un état autoritaire ou
totalitaire. C'est quoi le message que
veut faire passer la culture ou les
cultures françaises ou les formes de
culture française par l'exception
culturelle ? Aujourd'hui, on a entendu
frangler à longueur de journée viiew à
fond.
Oui, bah un peu pas bien. Euh
je je voilà, moi je suis par nature euh
par orgueil totalement à fond pour
l'exception culturelle française. Mais
aujourd'hui, vous demandez au pape
premier d'entre eux la le roi d'arier
Jacques Lang de culture d'État. C'est
quoi la c'est quoi l'exception
culturelle française que vous avez
confisqué, mis de côté, beaucoup
subventionné ? C'est quoi le message ?
Franchement, je ne sais pas. Moi je je
moi je suis toujours un peu j'essaie
toujours un peu de voir les phénomènes,
ça m'amuse. Alors un peu de l'anecdote
mais ou moi je je suis les je regarde
plus mais pendant longtemps j'ai subi
les la cérémonie des Césars euh pour
voir un peu ce qui se passe. J'essayie
quand même de d'écouter l'adversaire euh
puis de de sortir un peu de ma cage et
euh je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
quand il y a toujours
on est toujours très flatté de donne un
César d'honneur à des Américains. Voilà
c'est incroyable dès qu'il y a un
Américain qui daigne venir puis en plus
il dit merci en français alors là on est
par terre à PL vente. Incroyable qu'il
ait dit un mot français. Voilà. Bon et
alors à chaque fois, il y a un petit
discours sur pourquoi le cinéma français
est formidable et exceptionnel d'une
grande famille et ça ne manque jamais. À
95 %. Il va vous parler du cinéma de la
nouvelle vague donc d'une exception
culturelle française qu'à 50 ans au
moins. C'est pareil, vous avez des
romanciers qui vont venir sur France
Inter
formidable la France, j'adore Paris
machin, j'adore Paris et tout. J'adore
Paris, c'est l'amour. Mais bon et ils
vont vous dire c'est quoi ? Oui, des
grandes références du roman. C'était ça
b OK. Bon, moi j'ai oui, mais c'est ça
veut dire a rien aujourd'hui. C'est ça
la ma conclusion. Il y a rien. Il y a
pas rien mais c'est qu'en fait
l'influence de point de vue de gens qui
viennent nous faire plaisir et viennent
dire pourquoi l'exception culturelle
française compte dans l'empire culturel
que les États-Unis. C'est quoi ? Ils
vont pas vous dire un truc contemporain
alors qu'il y a des Français qui
réussissent sans doute ailleurs. Mais
souvent ils sont en anglais pour la
musique par exemple. Mais euh ils vont
vous citer des trucs 50 ans. Donc et ça
a l'air ça a l'air d'interpeller
personne que l'exception culturelle
française euh soit figé il y a 50 ans.
Moi ça m'interpelle d'ailleurs comme par
hasard c'était avec c'était c'était avec
deux goals, même si c'était leur
adversaire. Mais c'est peut-être un
hasard.
Dalida nous manque. C'est ça.
Bah bien sûr qu'elle nous manque Dalida
mais elle manque à beaucoup de gens et
il faut écouter Dalida.
Revenons aux ingérences
qui est très agressif et qui a des
résultats sur le sol français.
Mais les résultats principaux, c'est les
États-Unis.
C'est c'est la force d'ingérence de
toute façon de
ça se chiffre en milliard ou pas ?
J'ai pas envie de dire une bêtise. Mais
par sa proximité culturelle, par la
proximité des des
Qui qui d'autre derrière ?
Franchement derrière les États-Unis, il
y a pas grand monde, hein.
Juste derrière
le fossé. Euh après c'està-dire
que les États-Unis les États-Unis mais
je c'est pas pour me ou mais c'est c'est
pas pour me défausser en fait. Les
États-Unis réussissent à faire de
l'ingérance complète c'estàdire qu'ils
font ils ont l'ingérence géopolitique
évidemment à travers l'OTAN à travers un
certain nombre de programmes
diplomatiques des charges culturelles.
Ils ont une influence militaire
écrasante puisque malheureusement depuis
Sarkozy on n'est plus dans le la vision
du général de Gaulle.
Sarkozy nous a fait réintégrer
réintégrer le commandement intégré de
l'OTAN. Donc en fait, ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ? Ça veut dire qu'en fait
on a plus de projection. L'armée
française ne se n'envisage pas sa
projection autrement qu'à travers les
moyens les grands moyens américains et
une coopération purement atlantiste. Euh
culturel, j'en ai parlé économique
même le à travers les brevets. Vous
breuvez en anglais. Bon les les revues
de références scientifiques, c'est
nature, c'est pas sur Civil Junior. Bon,
mais non, mais c'est bien, mais c'est
pour la blague évidemment, mais je peux
plus, j'essaie toujours de de de
dramatiser alors qu'il y a rien, il y a
rien pour dédramatiser en fait. Voilà,
ils ont une influence et en plus
relativement invisible, plus
qu'agréable, y compris pour moi, pour
tout le monde. Donc donc le le le
comment vous dire, ils sont ils sont
incomparables.
Hubert Vidrine avait parlé de
l'hyperpuissance. Mais on est toujours
dans un phénomène d'hyper puissance.
Aon comparer ça à quoi ?
Je sais pas.
Puissance impériale.
Oui, je trouve je préfère le terme de de
de comment dire de Vedrine
parce que Aaron si vous voulez avait le
été inattaquable par rapport à son
profil. Puis en plus il était drôle
parce que Aaron était quand même assez
lié au cercle atlantiste mais le le le
comment dire nous on peut pas utiliser
ça. Puis il y aurait des confusions. Euh
voilà. Mais l'hyperpuissance, faut
vraiment se rendre compte à quel point
les États-Unis, pour tous les aspects
que les données ont une facilité à avoir
de l'influence en France. Voilà. De
toute façon, moi je suis rentré en
politique sur l'affaire Alstom. Voilà,
je suis entré alors j'essaie toujours,
je sais pas depuis combien de temps on
échange, mais de ne pas forcément
toujours en parler.
Ça fait 1h32 d'être en monomanie. J'ai
l'impression parfois d'être en monomanie
sur Alstom. Mais bon moi et je vais vous
dire à quel point c'était naturel.
J'étais j'ai le général électrique,
j'étais entre guillemets du côté du
méchant. Euh j'avais un tout petit
général électrique qui n'était pas un
méchant.
Bah du côté du méchant puisquon les ont
fait du mal à stom. Mais moi je venais
de faire les secs et c'est enance pot
j'avais pas fini. J'étais en
apprentissage. Alors moi aussi j'ai fait
un apprentissage mais je mélange pas.
Oui j'ai fait l'apprentissage. C'est ça
n'a rien à voir. C'est encore se donner
des attributs qu'on a pas. Bon bref,
mais j'étais là-dedans donc j'étais à la
fois à l'école, j'avais un tout petit
poste. Moi j'étais à la COB de la PDG de
la de la PDG de la holding de général
électrique France Clara Guemarc avait
une petite équipe d'une dizaine de
personnes. Moi, j'étais j'étais
apprenti, j'ai jamais réclamé avoir été
autre chose. Mais comme c'était une
toute petite équipe et que Clara Gemar
et d'ailleurs je paradoxalement je la
remercie pour ça,
la clé USB
Oui. avait une version avait une vision
horizontale du management, un peu à
l'américaine d'ailleurs, du management.
J'étais aux réunions, j'assistais à tout
et et vous savez un peu comme le sous
l'ancien régime, la première source de
d'espionnage, c'était les bonnes et les
les vallées.
C'est toujours le cas avec chose. Et ben
moi j'étais le j'étais le valet de Clara
Guemar. Elle pensait que j'étais la
tapisserie mais j'étais une tapisserie
avec des oreilles et un cerveau comme
d'ailleurs tous les Valais.
La DG la DGSE avait essayé de vous
tamponner un peu non rien à faire
strictement rien à faire.
Euh mais bon bref, en même temps quand
vous avez la femme, je je ne comment
dire je ne limite personne à son statut
sentimental, marital et une femme envers
un homme ou un homme envers une femme.
Mais quand vous avez la femme d'un
ancien ministre de l'économie qui a
autant de responsabilité dans
l'entreprise étrangère, il y a déjà pour
moins un problème. Bon euh il y a
toujours des
ou pas, elle a peut-être son libre
arbitre. Tout le monde a son libre
arbitre mais personne n'est libre de ses
intérêts quotidiens. Donc personne n'est
libre de ses intérêts quotidiens. Ça
n'existe pas. Et c'est comme ceux qui
sort d'une pièce en disant "Bah je suis
sorti de la pièce donc je suis déporté,
j'ai plus d'influence sur la réunion.
Comme si l'influence qu'on avait sur les
gens dépendait de fait qu'on ait les les
fesses un siège." Bon bref, bon tout ça
est grotesque. C'est la théorie des
apparences des élites françaises. Tout
ça grotesque. Si ça les gens que ça
rassure, tant mieux. Moi ça me rassure
pas. Bon bref. Bon de toute façon tout
cela était présenté comme parfaitement
normal. Euh et donc moi, je suis rentré
chez le généreux électrique en étant
persuadé que les qu'il y avait une
coopération amicale
pluriséculaire entre les États-Unis et
la France, que tout ce petit monde
travaillait bien ensemble, que général,
moi j'ai été recruté pourquoi général
électrique avait une stratégie de
communication qui s'appelait général
électrique français en France. Donc la
stratégie de communication c'était de
dire on est une entreprise américaine
mais quand on est en France on défend
les intérêts français. Et ben moi, j'y
ai cru au début mais mais la la le doigt
sous la couture. J'étais persuadé que
c'était vrai. Je n'avais aucune raison
de douter des intentions bienveillantes
de tout ce petit monde. Pour la petite
histoire, c'est vrai que le général
électrique quand je suis rentré en 2010
avait racheté un certain nombre d'outils
industriels français dont les Français
ne voulaient plus. Par exemple, Lex
Thompson, tout ce qui est scanner,
échographie, tout ça, mammographie dans
les Yvelines euh comment dire avait été
recapitalisé. refinancé par les
Américains. Donc je me dis bah oui,
c'est vrai là, les Français, ils avaient
abandonné cette pépite industrielle.
Heureusement qu'ils ont mis de l'argent.
Améin
moi, j'essaie d'être voilà, je suis pas
arrivé avec comment dire avec les
antennes comme ça. J'étais complètement
pigeon. Ça c'est chantel Goya et le
lapin. Ça
euh le moi j'y croyais et puis c'est au
fur et à mesure je me suis dit quand
même alors puis entre- temps, il y a eu
aussi un problème, c'est que quand tout
va bien, bon, il y a pas de raison
d'être désagréable mais 2010 la
palissade c'est après 2008 et en fait
2008 Chris surprise prime général
électrique qui historiquement dans
général électrique c'était l'entreprise
de Thomas Edison. Donc dans le
l'imaginaire américain, c'est comme
Schneedr ou Effel, ce sont des des
génies, des grands ingénieurs qui ont
vraiment façonner la société américaine.
Bon, tout le monde parle de l'ampoule,
mais au-delà de l'ampoule d'Edison,
c'est vraiment tout le système
électrique américain, euh la société de
consommation, l'électroménager pour le
foyer, voilà. Bah toute cette culture
des années 50 que tout le monde connaît,
qui a été un peu plus les familiarités
du plan marchal tout.
C'est toute cet imaginaire là. Mais au
fil des années, un peu comme en France
avec Alstom d'ailleurs, mais enfin
beaucoup moins grave, Gener électrique
était en fait devenu une banque
Gon Bank. D'une part de ils avaient cinq
grandes filiales. Sur les trois cinq
filiales, il y en avait deux qui étaient
Gony Bank, donc une des systèmes
bancaires et J Capital qui était
vraiment des activités de marché. Et le
en fait c'était devenu une mais donc ils
avaient l'exposition financière d'une
banque mais ils avaient pas la
réglementation bancaire. Donc en fait,
ils avaient le beurre, l'argent du
beurre et le cul des contribuables
puisqu'ils se font largement refinancés
par euh
le gouvernement américain pour ne pas
sombrer. Donc Général électrique sort de
la crise de 2008 traumatisé en se disant
une entreprise séculaire a failli crever
par les activités euh spéculatives qui
étaient pas leur métier historique. Et
donc ils font une translation massive
pour se redevenir une d'ailleurs ça n'a
pas marché. La fin de l'histoire, c'est
qu'à la fin ça va pas marcher
paradoxalement. Mais en tout cas à
l'époque, la tentative c'est qu' ils
font une grande translation de leurs
activités, de leur investissement pour
récupérer des usines. Or comme on me l'a
dit à une réunion très intéressante où
je disais "Ah bah tiens, alors on a qu'à
investir bah tiens dans les technologies
d'avenir dont on a parlé tout à l'heure,
une des directions de de clin électrique
me dit "Mon pauvre ami, j'ai vraiment
complètement con. Qu'est-ce qu'on va
s'emmerder à investir dans des
technologies pas matures ou à venir
alors qu'on peut racheter sur l'étagère
des entreprises ou des technologies qui
ont fait leur preuve ?" Donc on achète
sur étagère
et financer avec nos impôts
euh là les Américains non financier avec
les impôts des Américains en
l'occurrence. Alors après, il peut y
avoir des crédits, des choses
effectivement de l'optimisation mais là
générer électrique a massivement de
l'argent américain qui vient de la
politique de la banque centrale très
favorable qui vient de la
recapitalisation euh des plans de des
plans Obama tout ça.
Donc tout ce petit monde arrive en
France et donc à Rachette. Alors ça pas
commencé, moi j'ai pas connu le RCH
parce qu'on dit oui que je raconte que
je suis mythomane que je m'invente une
vie parce que je n'ai pas vu la racha
d'alstom quand j'étais en place. Quand
j'étais en place c'était le rachat d'une
ancienne filiale qui s'appelait
Convertim et tout le monde peut vérifier
c'est le plus gros LBO de l'histoire de
enfin en tout cas à l'époque où ça a été
fait c'était le plus gros lbbo de
l'histoire de France. Pour ceux qui ne
savent pas ce que c'est un LBO,
les watchout, c'est quand euh soit un
acteur financier extérieur, soit des
cadres de l'entreprise qui va être
démantelé lève euh comment dire achète
pas cher avec de l'emprunt une
entreprise et en fait vont se rembourser
soit sur la valeur qu'ils vont créer
avec ces entreprises, soit en faisant le
ménage et en faisant des coupes telles
qu'on dégage une rentabilité telle que
quelqu'un va le racheter et que vous
payez sur la rentabilité espérée par
celui qui va vous le racheter. Donc eux,
ils se présentent comme des chevaliers
blancs qui rétablissent ces entreprises.
C'est essentiellement du vol et euh du
massacre social, voire du massacre d'
biens public quand ça vient.
Oui, oui, c'est mon interprétation.
J'assume à 100 % des voleurs et des
parasites.
Donc le voleur et des parasites en
l'occurrence. Donc vous avez
quand soi-disant Sarkozy sauve Alstom
avec la coopération de l'Union
européenne, donc qui devrait évidemment
indiquer à tout le monde que ça ne va
sauver personne,
en fait démentelle une première fois
Stom. C'estd que en 2005 et c'était mon
grand conflit avec les gens de l'UMP qui
ont dit que Sarkozia a sauvé stom et qui
se sont un peu favoyés à cause de ça
avec tout le respect pour eux sur le
courage qu'ils ont eu pour ce beaucoup
de choses. En fait le problème d'Alstop
né avec le démantellement de Sarkozi qui
en fait pour recapitaliser un peu Alstom
avec Big
démantelle l'entreprise. Et donc dans ce
démantellement vous avez la transmission
la distribution qui est rachetée par
ARVA et vous avez ce qu'on appelait
Alstom conversion. Donc c'est un c'est
une technologie qui permet la la
conversion de l'électricité produite par
les générateurs vers le réseau. Bref euh
qui est aussi démantelé et là c'est il y
a LBO et donc c'est un des anciens
cadres de Alstom Conversion qui rachète
son entreprise en LBO et il le revend.
Je sais plus là, j'ai pas envie de dire
une bêtise mais en gros il doit
l'acheter 3 200 entre 200 et 400
millions d'euros et il le revend à
général électrique 2 milliards de
mémoire.
Bon, elle valait 2 milliards à la base.
Le problème n'est pas tant que lui il
est vendu 2 milliards que ça ressemble
un peu à l'effondrement de l'Union
soviétique et comme tous leur
Oui, exactement. Exactement. Des
oligarques, c'est effectivement comme la
chute de l'Union soviétique, des gens
rachètent à ville prix des entreprises
dans lesquelles ils n'ont aucune
responsabilité historique. He c'est pas
eux, c'est pas les oligarques russes qui
avaient créé la métallurgie russe ou les
ressources pétrolières ou gazières. Bah
là c'est pareil en France, vous avez des
arcs anciens polytechniciens bref des
grands corps de l'État qui ont à qui on
a confié des biens publics, à qui on a
confié le travail des Français plusieurs
décennies voir plusieurs siècles. Euh et
qui par qui confondent le bien public
avec leur portefeuille personnel et on
les laisse faire. En tout cas, on les a
laissé faire par le passé.
Je peux vous couper un peu ? Euh j'ai
j'ai vu une fois, je vous ai vu dans
l'Assemblée nationale raconter une
histoire qui était ahurrissante sur le
fait qu'il y a quelqu'un qui vous ait
attendu euh et qui vous ay vous avez eu
un cambriolage, euh quelqu'un vous a
attendu, vous avez eu une lame sous
l'œil. Euh c'est quoi cette histoire ?
Je vais pas me défiler mais juste
voudrais finir euh Alstom. Euh donc moi
j'assiste à ça. J'assiste à cette donc à
ce rachat. Il y avait aussi et puis donc
effectivement je j'ai beaucoup de
difficulté à raconter parce que comment
dire je ne suis pas libre de tout
raconter. Vous avez des accords, vous
avez des contrats. Il se trouve
qu'effectivement Clara Gamar à cette
époque le soir de le 24 au soir, le soir
de Noël repasse au bureau. C'est moi qui
étais de garde et en fait avait besoin
en urgence d'une clé USB. Euh comment
dire ma je je sais pas comment dire le
caractère. Enfin en gros j'étais en
panique. Où est-ce que je lui trouver
une clé USB le 24 au soir ? J'avais rien
d'autre. Moi-même, j'avais mon baluchon
pour partir dans ma famille à Ran.
Je lui donne une clé USB qui
m'appartenait, elle s'en sert et puis un
jour elle me la rend et puis elle avait
pas vidé. Voilà. Et sur cette clé USB,
il y avait si je vais vite euh tous les
échanges non pas lié à la futur
j'aimerais raconter ça au futur vende
stom en 2012 euh 2014 pardon mais toute
l'affaire passée du rachat enfin de la
tentative de rachat par le général
électrique de c'est pour ça j'en par
tout à l'heure de la filiale
transmission distribution d'Alstom qui
avait été revendue à Reva et ensuite à
Ra l'a revendu à la base d' Alstom mais
à l'époque les Américains voulaient
intervenir et en fait voulit racheter
euh voulait racheter ces activités
transmission et solution d'Alstom à la
place d'Alstom. C'est un peu compliqué,
je suis désolé, c'est vraiment des
montages compliqué. D'ailleurs, à
l'époque Anne Louvergeon, j'avais
interrogé en commission, m'a jamais
répondu, avait joué les Japonais pour
faire payer les Français plus chers.
Donc en plus entre nous, c'est vraiment
les loups quoi. Bon bref, donc j'ai
toute et en fait dans cette clé il y a
tous les coulisses,
il y a tous les coulisses de de
l'affaire de l'époque.
Vous avez eu un procès pour ça ? Vous
avez été accusé ? Procès de quoi ? Moi
m'a je n'ai rien révélé de secret et
surtout moi je suis enfin entre
guillemets je suis une victime
là-dedans. C'est moi quand ça m'est
tombé dessus, j'ai failli me j'ai failli
me flinguer hein. C'est en fait c'est
tellement violent de c'est pas le fait
que j'étais pas en danger à l'époque. Je
toujours pas d'ailleurs j'espère. Mais
en fait, moralement, vous croyez dans
quelque chose.
Vous croyez dans dans une méréitocratie,
vous croyez dans un système ? Vous
croyez que les élites qui gouvernent
sont là pour le bien public ? Pas que
c'est des anges, mais globalement pour
les biens publics. Vous croyez qu'il y a
des contrepouvoirs ? Vous croyez qu'il y
a des choses qui ne devraient pas être
possibles, qui sont possibles,
que il y a des choses qu'on vous dit
dans les médias offici dans les médias
pinan sur rue, vous dites "Bah, c'est de
l'information, c'est pas de
l'information, c'est de la une partie
pour une partie c'est de la propagande
qui a de l'argent derrière, qu'il y a
des gens euh qui devraient défendre
l'intérêt national et qui en fait euh
ne la défendent pas." Euh
bah c'est dur moralement. Alors c'est
pas dur. Ouais. C'est pas dur quand vous
perdez un proche, je suis pas en train
de me victimiser. Mais moralement quand
vous avez autant cru à ces valeurs et
que tout s'effondre,
enfin moi j'ai des amis qui m'ont
récupéré la petite cuillère et par
exemple c'est tellement dingue ma
famille m'a pas cru. Ça c'est aussi
après quand j'ai rencontré des lanceurs
d'alerte comme Stéphanie Gibau pour le
scandale UBS, on s'est on s'est on s'est
compris comme ça. En fait vous êtes dans
des situations fois plus moi j'ai
contrairement à elle ou d'autres j'ai
pas perdu mon emploi je suis pas chargé
de famille je suis pas en train de me
faire passer pour Cosette mais j'ai vécu
une chose semblable ce qui m'a fait
comprendre un certain nombre de
situations humaines de lanceur d'alerte
effectivement dans ces moments vous
dites c'est pas possible j'arrête quoi.
et j'ai retrouvé du sens par le combat
politique.
Donc j'ai ça et en fait parallèlement à
ça effectivement dès 2012 il y a des
information sérieuse que j'ai entendu
que j'ai constaté comme quoi après avoir
voulu racheter Alstom conversion qu'ils
ont réussi à acheter et Alstom
transmission distribution qu'ils ont
voulu réacheter où ils ont échoué
grâce à intervention de bouille à
l'époque le le comment dire le alstom
comme entité énergie et la prochaine
cible
C'est déjà discuté. Voilà. Et ceux qui
d'ailleurs essay de faire croire aux
gens, vous avez auditionné d'autres
personnes sur ce sujet-là, de essayer de
faire croire aux gens que le plus gros
rachat de l'histoire de France et une
des plus gros rachats de l'histoire de
l'industrie américaine se serait fait en
quelques jours en 2014 entre deux verres
euh comment dire ? C'est pas le fouet
pour les Américains, c'est un autre au
Bristol. C'est une plaisanterie. Voilà,
c'est une plaisanterie. Et d'ailleurs,
je me suis donc engagé avec du poignant
en lui disant je viens je viens
m'engager avec vous parce que ce que
j'ai vu chez le général électrique est
très grave euh que les les élites
françaises ne défendent pas la France et
avec à l'époque je pense que monsieur
Dupourignan très courageux d'ailleurs,
il l'a été puisqu'il m'a fait confiance
sur ça comme sur d'autres choses euh sur
son combat européen. Moi, c'est
quelqu'un d'intègre, honnête et
courageux malgré les désaccords que j'ai
eu avec lui.
et il m'a jamais détrompé hein.
C'està-dire moi, ça fait 3 ans que je
suis élu, j'ai raconté cette histoire
alors peut-être avec des journalistes
qui l'ont un peu transformé moins
directement mais monsieur Dupignant ne
m'a jamais a jamais contesté que quand
je suis venu le voir, je lui ai raconté
ça. Hein
cette histoire de cambriolage, c'était
le hasard cette histoire.
Oui. Alors après voilà et donc après
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? C'est que au
moment 2014 effectivement j'étais en
déplacement à messe avec enfin en Lorè
avec du Poignant. Je rentre euh ma porte
n'est pas fracturée, c'est une fenêtre
qui permet de rentrer, je pas le dire
mais qui permettait avant que je la
sécurise de aucune raison de la
sécuriser euh qui rentre chez moi et en
fait mon appartement est cambriolé mais
seulement les papiers, les disques durs,
le les ordinateurs et c'était signé si
vous voulez dans le sens où tous les
biens tous les choses qui avaient
vraiment de la valeur
comme quoi
bah
l'offre a berger
non je sais pas vous avez un peu
d'argent liquide chez vous une montre
bon c'est pas une montre grande valeur.
Bon enfin c'est une montre qu'on va vous
faire à ma communion. Enfin en je dis
des objets si tout ce que fait qu'on
vole normalement si vous voulez
normalement vous cambriolez un
appartement vous prenez pas les archives
papier le disque dur et euh ordinateur
enfin l'ordinateur à la limite oui c'est
peut-être que la valeur enfin vous
prenez pas le disque dur ça vaut 100
balles et vous prenez pas comment dire
les papiers alors quand je suis allé
voir d'ailleurs la façon une fois plus
moi j'ai dit devant tout le monde il y a
personne n'a dit que j'avais menti à
l'époque et tout je suis allé voir la
police mais de bonne fois la police qui
m'a dit oh bah c'est sans doute des
Romes des gitans parce que dans le
quartier il y a il y a des campements de
gitans qui ont fait et voilà, je dis oui
bah ils ont pris le papier pour faire un
feu de joie quoi. Ils ont quand je vous
ai dit papier c'était plusieurs caisses
vousz de papier là de barrettes quoi.
C'était plusieurs caisses. Donc bon plus
dedans une fois de plus il y a pas de
grand-chose hein.
Il y a pas de quoi faire sauter la
République mais il y avait ma petite vie
à moi de mon expérience personnelle qui
me permettait de mieux comprendre
comment fonctionnait. Qu'est donné
l'enquête ?
Comment
qu'est-ce qui a donné l'enquête ?
Rien classé.
Il y a eu un relevé d'empreinte chez
vous. Oui oui, ils sont venus très
gentils d'ailleurs les policiers parce
que je trava du poignant, j'étais déjà
personnalité politique exposée donc il y
a il y a eu des empreintes et tout mais
ça n'a rien mais les pauvres dire ils
ont tellement de cambriolage tellement
d'affaires qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'il fasse voilà et donc il y a eu ça
voilà bon j'ai eu un deuxième
cambriolage mais qui est moins évident
donc après faut c'est très compliqué de
pas devenir complètement dingue.
C'estàd vous avez vous avez vous avez
pas posé des pieds jaloux chez vous ?
Non, en fait j'en ai en fait j'en ai
tiré, c'est un peu ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure sur mon téléphone, j'en
ai tiré la conclusion que soit tu fais
très très attention à un très haut
niveau, soit en fait tu peux rien faire.
C'est pas de taille. Voilà, donc faut
arrêter de ça sert à rien.
La mine la mine antipersonnelle, les
pieds jaloux, c'est pas mal.
Je crois pas que ça fonctionne mais
voilà, ça sert à voilà ça sert à rien.
C'est des personnes de confiance qui ont
ces éléments. Voilà. Mais voyez en fait
vous
cette histoire cette histoire de l'âme
sous l'œil, ça s'est passé comment ?
Voilà. Donc ça c'est autre et c'est là
vous voyez où faut dire comment
qu'est-ce qui est de la vérité,
qu'est-ce qui est de la paranoï. Donc
pendant les élections européennes de
2019, donc c'était 3e de liste de la
liste de duignant. Alors on dit bah oui
mais c'est une liste qui a pas fait un
score au début de la campagne on était à
10 % dans les sondages. Donc on aurait
pu faire un score, faut pas réécrire les
choses par la fin. Bon bref le dernier
le le
l'avant-dernier soir pardon le weekend
de la semaine d'avant le comment dire
les les élections pardon. Je sors euh
très tard tout seul du comment dire du
siège de Debou la France à l'époque qui
était euh près du parc George Brassins.
et je m'engage sur la route qui mène au
métro et puis je vois un individu dans
un garage sous un chemin qui me fait un
garage souterrain à contrejour un homme
de dos enfin de 2 tiers et je vous
voyais qu'il venait du Moyen-Orient et
puis je me dis écoute il avait l'air
louche il m'aspirer pas confiance mais
je me dis écoute leur fille c'est pas
possible tu vas pas juger les gens sur
leur physique leur apparence machin tu
fais ta vie tu traces tu passes à côté
de lui et tu changes pas de trottoir
voilà bon mais c'est vraiment que j'ai
vraiment pensé ça alors que mon
intuition me disait de changer de
trottoir en plus bref Donc je passe
devant et il m'attrape par derrière euh
en me faisant une clé autour du cou. Il
essaie de me faire tomber. Il se trouve,
désolé pour ceux qui pensent que je suis
une chotte totale, que j'arrive à me
libérer. Euh pas chot
non mais parce qu'il y a des gens qui
disent des choses odieuses. Euh le le
que c'est impossible pour un homosexuel
de se défendre physiquement. Voilà. Bon
je
jamais joué au rugby.
Non, j'ai pas le carur pour jouer au
rugby et j'ai encore des réflexes.
Voilà. Euh bref, je
la gonflette un peu
un peu mais c'est de combat. C'est
surtout parce que je j'ai plus le temps
de faire de sport de combat. Mais c'est
surtout que je suis
Vous avez fait quoi comme sport de
combat ?
Bon, j'ai fait du karaté. Bon, enfin,
j'étais pas très bon.
Non, non, mais rien chuto, rien du tout.
Chuto, totalement amateur. Il y a rien à
tirer là-dessus. C'est quoi ?
J'en sais rien. J'ai je faisais ça pour
me faire plaisir. Je n'ai jamais je Il y
a rien à tirer là-dessus. Voilà, je fais
du sport essentiellement pour être en
forme.
Revenons à vos appuis.
Bref, j'arrive à me libérer une deuxième
fois. il me ressaisit et là il sort ce
que je sens parce que je ne vois pas
être une lame au point de vue ici de
l'ine en me disant "Mets-toi", tout
était en anglais avec un accent du
Moyen-Orient euh "Mets-toi à genou,
mets-toi à terre, il me colle machin, il
me met lame, il me l'enfonce dans la
paupière en bas et il me dit "Si tu ne
me donnes pas ton téléphone, je te crève
l'œil." Tout ça en anglais, je crève
l'œil, tu donnes je donne mon portable.
Il voulait le code, je lui donne le code
et après ce qui m'a interpellé à
l'époque, il a voulu vérifier mon
identité et donc je lui ai donné ma
carte vitale. Bon bref, ça c'est pour
les détails. C'est ça en fait qui
m'interpellé pourquoi il veut mon
identit
qui veuille mon code soit qui veille
vérifier que j'étais bien Jean-Philippe
Tangui alors que j'étais quand même
personne. Enfin je toujours d'ailleurs
vérifier si c'était le bon contrat.
Voilà. Bon donc je il s'en va enf il me
remonace de mort enfin truc habituel.
Euh je reprends un peu mes esprits, je
retourne sur mes pas
au siège de Debout la France. J'appelle
meilleurs amis et collègues qui
aujourd'hui députés qui s'appelle Thomas
Ménager qui débarque et voilà, il
m'emmène à la police et dès le moment
là,
moi je lui dis tout de suite et
d'ailleurs après il s'en est voulu
personnellement tout, je lui dit écoute
c'est pas normal, c'est très bizarre,
c'est louche. Il dit écoute, tu nous
fais chier avec ta parano parce que je
faisais déjà chier avec l'affaire stom
depuis 2019 depuis 7 ans. Du coup, tu
nous saoules avec tes histoires de de de
paranoï machin, tu nous emmerdes, tu
nous as claé le coup.
Euh bah chien du poignant dit écoute
fatigue, vous êtes fait agressé. Voilà.
Bon donc mais je vais quand même à la
police, je le dis. Bon puis là en fait
il y a un enchaînement de choses
foireuses.
Donc on vous dit exagère. Donc déjà bah
je fais un témoignage. Oui. Bon bah j'
façon vous savez entre ce que vous
racontez et ce que vous mettez par la
plainte écrit il y a pas forcément ce
que vous voulez hein. Donc déjà pour
ceux qui ont la fait porter plainte tout
le monde sait très bien que le rendu de
la police c'est pas forcément même si
vous le signez c'est un compromis aussi
sur ce que vous avez raconté. Et puis
écoutez vos histoires à la con vous
virez on vire. Bon, première chose,
pas eu de chance parce que d'habitude
les policiers ils vous aident à formuler
vos idées, à rassembler vos souvenirs.
Mais c'est pas qu'ils étaient méchants,
mais en faut il faut que ça ressemble il
fallait pas ils aiment pas les trucs un
peu bizarres farfelus quoi. Bon,
deuxième chose, il me dit on dit oui
pour mon les agressions physiques. Il me
dit bon alors soit vous allez à
l'hôpital soit on fait une photo, ça
vaut pareil. Alors moi, j'ai fait une
photo. Bon, j'aurais pas dû. Bah, c'est
comme ça. Mais c'est sur le moment une
fois plus he pour tous ceux qui sont
victimes. Ne faites pas de photo, il
faut aller à l'hôpital. Euh puis voilà
et puis bon se passe et puis en parle
tout le monde même ma mère me dit pauvre
s'en veut aussi tu n'es pour rien maman
voilà sans me dit mais écoute tu nous
fais chier tu exagères tu t'es fait
agresser c'est la vie on avance et tout
bon et puis bon voilà et puis alors une
semaine plus tard euh
mon téléphone se reconnecte via
Instagram enfin Facebook enfin Facebook
via Instagram enfin les deux étaient
connectés et ça ça
connecte
à Chypre et à Televive. Donc là, je
retourne voir les policiers. Chpre
d'abord Tav, je retourne voir les
policiers, je leur dis "Écoutez, moi je
veux bien que ce soit juste une
agression mais enfin je vous avais dit
que c'était bizarre et là une fois plus
ça me paraît bizarre."
Bon alors on modifie un peu, on refit
j'ai refait un dépôt de plainte une fois
plus la police était très bien. Puis
soit je me souviens à l'époque, il me
dit "Bah écoutez, c'est bizarre,
protégez-vous, j'ai pas les moyens de
protéger." Bref euh et une semaine
repasse, donc c'était pas une semaine
avant les élections, c'était de
semaines. Euh et là vraiment quelques
jours avant les avant les élections euh
comment dire euh là il y a des
diffusions de mon téléphone. Alors à la
fois des choses vraies et aussi des
choses fausses sur Twitter donc le
contenu de mon téléphone qui sort
machin. Voilà. Bon et donc viser pour
perturber la campagne, m'attaquer
personnellement, tout ça. Bon bon euh
bon tout ça j'ai avec Twitter ça a été
enlevé mais si vous voulez montrant bien
montrant bien évidemment que ce n'était
pas juste une agression mais que c'était
ciblé sur ma personne. Et là vous avez
deux choix voilà c'est qu'est-ce que
pourquoi j'étais agressé ? Je n'en sais
rien. Voilà. Et donc en fait, j'ai eu le
malheur de d'expliquer aux journalistes
qu'il y avait soit deux raisons
principales, soit la raison principale
était effectivement le dossier Alstom
sur lequel j'ai étais engagé depuis très
longtemps, soit était une agression
de de des nazillons qui traînent
malheureusement à Paris et qui ont
quelque chose contre moi depuis très
longtemps. Voilà. Bon, je ne sais pas
quelle est euh la thèse d'ailleurs, la
deux thèse, ça peut être l'extrême
droite. Enfin bon, j'en sais rien.
Voilà, c'est pas à moi de le savoir et
c'est pas de ma faute si l'enquête n'a
mener à rien. Voilà, il toujours des
inversions contrad accusatoires si vous
voulez. Vous êtes victime et à la fin on
dit "Oui, mais tu t'es peut-être trompé,
tu as mal décrit ton truc." Oui,
effectivement, je suis pas une caméra
embarquée et parfois je peux dire des
erreurs. Voilà. Mais c'est exactement ce
qu'a stubbi Stéphanie Gibo qui que
j'aime beaucoup et qui est très
courageuse et qui a été très maltraité
par l'État français ou d'autres. on
l'embrasse,
c'est toujours des des inversions
accusatoires comme ça. Donc en tout cas
cette agression, elle a existé. Euh il
se trouve que celui qui m'a récupéré les
députés et il peut en témoigner que
Nicolas Dupignan qui m'a accueilli à
l'époque sait très bien sait très bien
pourquoi je suis venu avec lui et le
combats que j'ai mené tout ce que j'ai
dit tout ce que j'avais annoncé entre
2012 et 2014 sur Alstom c'est c'est
produit après. Donc soit je suis un
extra lucide un Nostradamus des temps
modernes soit la seule réalité qui est
c'est que ce que je lui avais annoncé
était la vérité et qu'il s tout
simplement produit ce qui devait se
produire.
On n pas énormément de temps. Ça fait
que bientôt 2h qu'on est en interview.
1h57. Je voudrais qu'on abandonne
mais ceci dit quand j'ai raconté ça à
l'assemblée,
j'ai jamais été l'enquête n'a pas été
ouverte. Tu vois, on pourrait se dire
bon entre-temps, je suis devenu député,
je suis un peu je fais un peu des
médias, tout ça.
Mais et personne n'a contesté hein.
Enfin, je une fois plus si vous regardez
cette vidéo a eu un c'est pas pour me
vanter, enfin elle a eu il trouve
qu'elle a eu un certain succès,
vous n'avez personne n'a contesté ce que
je dis dedans.
Vous avez regardé quelques-unes de nos
vidéos ?
Oui, ça m'est arrivé. Bah, notamment à
l'époque quand vous aviez reçu du
poignant pour préparer un peu
l'entretien. J'avais regardé
Fré Pierucci, vous avez regardé ?
Oui, je connais bien Fred Pierucci.
D'ailleurs, je parle de lui dans dans la
vidéo. Quelqu'un de fois plus. Moi je
j'ai j'ai soucié de faire attention aux
personnes que je cite parce que je veux
pas les politiser. Frédéric Piroui n'est
pas politique. Il n'a jamais été. Il ne
voudra jamais l'être et ça entière
liberté et de son point de vue il a sans
doute raison. Je pense que sa famille a
suffisamment vécu d'injustice. Mais
voilà ce qui s'est arrivé quand je
m'explique mieux que tout le monde se
foute de la petite de la triste anecdote
qui m'est arrivée. Quand lui qui a été
emprisonné dans une prison de haute
sécurité pour terroristes alors qu'il
était innocent, pris enage pendant des
années, ça n'a eu aucune conséquence sur
l'État français. Et donc on remet en
perspective quand on sait que l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 s'est joué sur un
mensonge d'État sur les ingérences
russes au RN qui étaient que des
mensonges qui a pris des proportions
complètement dingues. Alors que quelque
chose d'avéré le fait que le social
macronisme
Macron au land des compagnies et laissé
un net un innocent Frédéric Pirucci pris
en otage pendant plusieurs années dans
une prison d'aute sécurité française que
tout le monde le savait qu'ils n'ont
presque rien fait pour le libérer et que
il ne vit aujourd'hui que parce qu'il a
du talent et qu'il a des ressources
propres et que l'État français en a rien
à [__] et qu'en plus dans l'espoir de
personnel de Frédéric Pieroui il y a la
liquidation d'Alstom donc la liquidation
de notre souveraineté de nos
technologies nucléaire
des technologies de nos barrages et de
toute la transformation de la
distribution de l'électricité. Écoutez
voilà, à partir du moment où la
démocratie française n'est pas capable
de mettre au centre du débat un tel
scandale d'état où un compatriote a été
retenu en otage par une puissance
soit-disant amie, qu'est-ce que vous
dise ?
Vous avez suivi le le Rusian Gate aux
États-Unis,
le le les accusations sur Trump ? Bah,
j'ai je suivis euh de loin quoi. J'ai vu
que ça n'avait pas enfin que ça n'avait
pas mené à grand-chose quoi. Oui.
Euh est-ce qu'il y a une interconnexion
entre le pouvoir macroniste et euh la
nomination de quelques-uns euh chez
Hstom
à postériori ?
Oui.
Bah ça, j'ai pas la preuve.
Très bien. Euh euh
ou c'est là où faut faire attention
parce que par exemple mais voyez le le
monsieur Pécit là pour le ce qui a avéré
que c'était l'agent de liaison. Enfin,
pardon, c'était le référent.
euh de général électrique dans
l'intégration d'Alstom.
On un sens.
Donc c'était le référent, c'était la
personne référente de génér au sein
d'Alstom pour faire l'intégration des
activités énergétiques d'Alstom à génér.
Voilà, là c'est inattaquable.
C'est quoi le le proverbe ? Les mots un
sens,
je sais pas,
on le succé sur le sens vous. Là, je
suis concentré sur autre chose. Euh,
j'essaie de vous déconcentrer.
Bah, c'est ça fon parfois ça fonctionne,
je le regrette le le donc euh mais par
contre après quand euh la suite de la
carrière de monsieur PCR, il avait été
accusé de choses qui finalement se sont
pas avérées. Bon, donc faut faire
attention. Voilà.
Bon, l'assemblée va être dissoute ou pas
? Par contre, le fait que Valérie PC
lorsqu'elle a été candidate à la
présidentielle n'a jamais été interrogée
sur les quelques centaines de milliers
d'euros dont ça don son foyer s'était
enrli par l'affaire halstom, ça c'est un
problème. C'est
peut-être le hasard.
Ah bah c'est pas un hasard mais le fait
que personne lui posait il y a pas un
pourtant je peux dire je me suis agité
hein. Jamais la question lui a été
posée. Ah mais non c'est la femme de je
m'en fiche soit la femme. Ce serait
Valérie qui serait à la place de son
mari ou l'inverse je poser la même
question. Le genre de la personne n'a
strictement aucun intérêt. Mais voilà,
la cause féministe est utilisée pour pas
poser les questions qui dérangent.
C'est votre interprétation.
Bah écoute,
euh la dissolution François Berou, la
dette, on prend dans quel sens et on
tire la bobinette comment ? Si Berou n'a
pas la confiance, dans 2 jours, il y a
la note des agences de notation qui vont
nous dégrader. Donc, on va payer plus
cher notre dette et ça va être un cercle
vicieux.
Est-ce qu'il faut maintenir Berou pour
éviter que la dégradation de la note
française ? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Non
mais c'est l'inverse, c'est évidemment
parce que en fait ça fait longtemps
qu'on aurait dû dégrader. La note
aujourd'hui la notif la note de la
France, la note de la dette souveraine
de la France est aujourd'hui
anormalement élevé et les agences de
notation qui ont eu un rôle dramatique
proche de l'escroquerie dans la crise
des S prime euh continue leur méfet
raconter n'importe quoi. Et en fait la
note en tout cas pour ce qui est des
dettes souveraines que les agences vous
donnent dépend au stand de vos réseaux
et de vos amitiés au sein de ces agences
que de la réalité économique de la de la
France. Donc là ça
c'est de la supputation. Ils travaillent
peut-être d'une façon acharnée mais ils
se trompent.
Oui. Ou ils ont des informations que
personne n'a et qu'ils sont incapables
de justifier quand ils sont pris la main
dans la confiture. Mais mais en tout cas
la note de la France ne comment dire
n'est pas en accord avec la réalité de
ses finances publiques. Pas de son
économie hein mais de on n'est pas
situation de la Grèce mais de de comment
dire de de de ces finances publiques. 50
ans de déficit structurel. Euh le on est
le premier émetteur de dette, on est le
premier émetteur euh de dettes euh
depuis plusieurs années en euros alors
que ça devrait être proportionnellement
par rapport à l'économie. Évidemment,
l'Allemagne euh bon il y a il y a rien
qui va
ça va y venir et
que l'Allemagne va s'end encore plus.
Oui, mais pour d'autres raisons euh et
ce sera bien triste pour la France mais
là aujourd'hui c'est la situation telle
qu'elle est. Aucun plan de redressement.
Il y a quelqu'un, j'ai oublié qui qui a
sorti un graphique très intéressant.
Vous voyez les prévisions de tous les
gouvernements depuis le traité de
Mastriff sur le rétablissement des
finances publiques avec des courbes de
redressement et vous voyez à chaque fois
avec d'ailleurs la même régularité les
plans de redressement qui échouent.
Voilà, donc c'est pas un plan de
redressement des finances publiques qui
a échoué, c'est tous les plans après en
gros après baladure
et encore plus une fois qu'on est
vraiment rentré enfin que la zone euro s
c'est s'est développée donc après 2001
où vraiment tous les plans de
redressement des finances publiques se
sont complètement se sont complètement
effondrés. Donc il y a aucune
crédibilité de la France, enfin en tout
cas des des gouvernements du système à
rétablir les finances publiques. Donc
pour moi, c'est évidemment l'inverse.
Tout le monde a parlé du 10 du 10
septembre, pardon, donc des
manifestations du 10 septembre et comme
quoi Beou avait mis sa tête sur le bio,
enfin avait mis son gouvernement en jeu
euh pour éviter d'être accusé par le 10
septembre. C'est pas évidemment le 10
septembre, c'est évidemment la notation
euh de la France qui est dans le
calendrier compte. Euh et c'est évident
parce que si la France est dégradée
selon la dégradation, on rentre dans une
zone de vraie turbulence puisque pour
des raisons réglementaire et et de
règles prudentielles qui seraient trop
longues à exposer, euh comment dire un
certain nombre de fonds de pension, de
fonds d'investiss fond d'investissement
de banque d'assurance ne peuvent
investir dans des titres que s'ils ont
une certaine note de sûreté et que si la
la France passe dessous un certain
grade, ces fonds ne pourront plus
emprunter légalement en fait. en tout
cas de manière prudentielle à la France
et donc bah forcément on va devoir
emprunter auprès des fonds plus risqués,
plus exposés et qui parce qu'ils sont
exposé même si c'est aussi une fiction
plus de rendement
demande plus de rendement. Bon même si
tout ça est aussi très fictionnel.
Nicolas qui
vous en pensez ?
Mais c'est vous Nicolas quié c'est
finalement une un épigone des gilets
jaunes. C'est c'est espèce de comment
dire
épigone 50 points.
Hm.
On est un jeu entre nous. Ah, c'est une
incarnation nouvelle d'un d'un phénomène
ancien et légitime de de la France du
travail qui se rend bien compte qu'
porte l'appareil d'État que l'argent
public c'est l'accumulation de l'argent
du contribuable et qui se rend bien
compte que la qualité des services
publics, la gestion de l'argent public
ne correspond pas à l'effort qu'on leur
demande et qui est toujours et et on en
revient à ce qu'on dis en début
d'entretien sur François Berou qui
explique aux Français que vraiment si on
est ruiné c'est leur faute à eux alors
qu'ils ont payé leurs impôts. Il y a pas
d'autre là la France dans une situation
particulière parce que par exemple
prenez le modèle grec enfin le modèle
grec ce qui s'est passé en Grèce de
bonne fo estimer que beaucoup de
contribuables grecs y compris pas juste
les plus riches ou les moines du moins à
mais vraiment beaucoup de beaucoup de de
comment dire de contribuables grecs ne
payent pas leur juste part d'impôts.
l'économie informelle,
l'église.
Oui, ben c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé
des moines. Euh les les comment dire le
le voilà que il y a un problème de de de
de participation de bonne foi à l'effort
à l'effort financier en Grèce. En
France, c'est pas le cas. En France
quasi totalité, sauf les ceux qui ont
les moyens de faire l'optimisation
fiscale pai leur juste titre. Alors,
vous avez tout à l'heure les pourboir.
Voilà, peut-être que les serveurs ou
quelqu'un qui fait des travaux chez
vous, une coiffeuse, vous lui filez 1 €
Oh là là, c'est pas déclaré. Voilà,
c'est ça l'économie. Enfin à part la
drogue, c'est ça l'économie informelle
euh en France. Donc les gens paient
évidemment euh rebiss sur l'ongle euh
leur impôt en France et donc quand on
leur disent bah vous avez pas assez
contribués et c'est de votre faute.
C'est insupportable. Donc Nicolas Kipé
euh euh c'est ça euh c'est ce symptôme
là.
C'est c'est l'extrême droite Nicolas qui
?
Non mais si c'est ça les sien alors là
pour si Nicolas Kippé c'est l'extrême
droite ça veut dire que l'extrême droite
déjà gagné en France mais l'extrême
droite en France c'est 1 %. Alors, leur
Assemblée nationale pour ce qu'il est,
il est port du pouvoir et d'ailleurs aux
dernières élections, si vous retirez les
nouveaux ennemis de monsieur Berérou,
les boomers, euh c'est quand même
particulier aussi hein, quand on insulte
son l'électorat qui vous tient comme la
corde tient le pendu, c'est quand même
psychologiquement c'est intéressant
quand même. Euh bon bah là si c'était
que la France qui travaille, c'està dire
la France qui n'est pas à la retraite ou
étudiante, bon bah Marine Le Pen serait
l'Élysé hein. Question internet.
De nombreuses personnes sur le chat
Twitch considèrent qu'il ne faut pas
vous inviter, ne pas vous laisser la
parole. Comment percevez-vous ce genre
de discours ? Le RN engendre 25 à 30 %
des vos élections. Comment réconcilier
de France ? Mais
je pense pas qu'on soit fâché. Je pense
pas qu'il y a de France. Je pense que
les les certains responsables politiques
médiatiques alimentent. D'ailleurs,
c'est un peu les éléments de langage en
ce moment pour sauver les fesses du
gouvernement. C'est oui la guerre
civile. Si c'est pas nous, c'est la
guerre civile. Si Marine Le Pen gagne,
c'est la guerre civile. Mais aussi
d'ailleurs si Mélenchon gagne, c'est la
guerre civile, il y aura beaucoup de
problèmes avec Mélenchon. Euh ce sera
pas la guerre civile. Voilà. Bon ça donc
c'est espèce de de langage excessif
assez grottesque. Je regrette que les
gens tombent dedans. Voilà. Voilà. Moi
je pense qu'on a un entretien qui vaut
ce qui vaut. Je mets au défi ceux qui
veulent pas que je sois là de dire à
quel moment j'ai des propos d'extrême
droite. Bon courage.
Question internet.
Comment monsieur Tangy compte-il changer
la France en étant sous telle de
l'Europe ? Entre parenthèses cas de
l'Allemagne,
n'est-ce pas vouloir changer la couleur
de la coque du navire mais pas le
naufrage ? Point d'interrogation. Non,
on peut faire des changements
fondamentaux, mais la seule solution,
c'est les référendums. Il est évident
que tout programme politique qui ne
repose pas sur la convocation euh
fondamental, c'est-à-dire sur des lois
très importantes, euh l'immigration euh
sans doute des lois de souveraineté
économique euh sur le référendum
effectivement est un programme pour du
beur. Le référendum aujourd'hui, on
revient au fait que moi je suis
populiste. La parole sacrée et
clairement exprimée par référendum du
peuple français est aujourd'hui le seul
instrument politique que nous avons pour
redéfinir les grandes contraintes
européennes. Premier aspect. Deuxième
aspect, quand vous êtes armé de ce
référendum et seulement quand vous êtes
armé de ce référendum, vous pouvez
établir un rapport de force avec vos
partenaires européens. Et même si la
France est dans une grande difficulté
économique, nous sommes encore le 2e
contributeur euh brut et surtout net euh
de l'Union européenne et le général de
Gaul avait fait le la politique de la
chaise vide. Moi, j'ai conseil à Marine
et à Jordane de Marine Le Pen, Jordan
Bardella de faire le politique du
portefeuille vide.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du DSA ?
J'ai honnêtement avec vous, j'ai jamais
réussi à me faire une opinion. J'ai
jamais réussi à
C'est quoi le DSA ? passer la
réglementation européenne sur qui soit
disant doit nous protéger de de
l'impérialisme numérique euh mais en
place par Terry Breton. Mais je je suis
honnête avec vous, je je n'ai jamais eu
le temps. Vous voyez bon, j'essaie une
fois plus, il rassemble beaucoup de
monde qui aura beaucoup de critiques à
me faire et c'est légitime mais j'essaie
quand même de maîtriser les sujets de A
à Z. Et là, je me suis jamais exprimé
sur ce sujet parce que je n'ai jamais eu
le temps physique entre les finances,
l'industrie, l'agriculture de me
consacrer à ce dossier. Donc à titre
personnel euh
je n'ai pas j'ai pas d'opinion
aujourd'hui intéressante à donner aux
gens sur ça.
Vous avez une opinion sur Je regrette
hein, j'ai pas le temps.
Vous avez une opinion sur Musk ?
Oui, mais est-ce que c'est intéressant
d'avoir une opinion sur des personnes ?
Pour moi, c'est un génie. Mo moi si vous
voulez ce qui me mais voyez regarde en
disant ça
il fait de l'ingérance
je sais pas j'ai je sais pas d'élément
est que c'est de la maladresse ou de
l'ingérance qu'il a fait en Allemagne
notamment au Royaume-Uni s'est fait
jeter par exemple par Farage
Irlande quand il soutient le
j'ai pas vu en Irlande ce qu'il a fait
en comment dire en Allemagne
effectivement ça allait un peu plus loin
est-ce que vraiment ça a eu de
l'influence sur les gens je sais pas je
veux dire moi je suis souverainiste donc
je pense évidemment la souveraineté
nationale mais je crois aussi que les
peuples ont une identité une culture une
civilisation propre et en fait de toute
façon je pense qu'un un un comment dire
un ressortissant d'Afrique du Sud qui
vient faire des leçons politiques dans
une démocratie allemande ou autre n'a
rien à dire en fait à cette démocratie
et que les Allemands ils vont entendre
un un mec qui vient d'Afrique du Sud
avec la culture Afrique du Sud un peu
américanisé. Qu'est-ce qu'il a à dire
sur le passé, le présent et l'avenir de
l'Allemagne ? À mon avis, rien. Donc ce
genre d'ingérence fonctionne pas très
bien là.
On avis où il y a une ingérence, c'est
que aujourd'hui, c'est ça en fait sans
doute qui devrait être un débat, c'est
un peu lié au DSA de manière générale,
c'est qu'on a le retour, c'est J'enfonce
une porte ouverte, d'autres gens bien
plus compétents on dit 10 mois, on a le
retour d'une forme de multinationale qui
joue un peu le rôle qu' pouvit avoir la
compagnie des Indes certain nombre de de
de puissances paraétatique, commerciale,
privée,
colonial qui était capable de dessiner
des cartes entières ici en Afrique, ici
en Inde, ici aux Antilles,
sur le continent américain.
et que les intérêts privés étaient en
collusion permanente avec un
détournement de l'intérêt public. Et
aujourd'hui, on a des multinationales
qui ont un pouvoir quasiment souverain.
La puissance financière là, j'ai vu qu'
allait se faire offrir 1000 € 1000
milliards d'euros d'action de dollars
d'action. Je sais pas à quoi ça aboutira
vraiment, mais les montants sont
complètement fabuleux. De toute façon,
je vois la capitalisation de Tesla, je
crois que c'est c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliards de de dollars.
Milard, ça fait quand même un peu
beaucoup, non ?
Ah non, je l'ai vu, il y avait vraiment
1000 milliards là. Là, il a une promesse
de son board de lui faire 1000 milliards
d'actions. Alors, sans doute un putaclic
et il y a sans doute quelque chose de
plus compliqué à la fin. C'est ce que
j'ai c'est ce que j'ai dit. Mais de
toute façon, on voit bien aujourd'hui
que Tesla qui est valorisé plusieurs
centaines de milliards de dollars
pendant que Renault Renault Stellentis à
E2, on doit être à 20 milliards euh les
bonjour. Bon, on se rend bien compte
qu'un certain nombre euh Apple qui ont
des pouvoirs de marché pas seulement de
marché pardon, au-delà d'un pouvoir de
marché, des pouvoirs d'ingérence mais
financière de lobbying considérable et
et de ne pas le voir, ne pas en parler,
c'est complètement hypocrite. Et par
exemple aujourd'hui, c'est quoi
l'ingérence de ces multinationales ?
très concret et personne n'en parle à
part, il faut bien le dire, Assemble
nationale et un peu les insoumis, c'est
euh le le le le cheval de 3 qui est
l'Irlande.
énorme paradis fiscal, moi je dis
parasite fiscal au sein de l'Europe qui
profite du marché commun qui s'enrichit
sur notre dos et le le l'ingérence la
puissance de ces multinationales sur le
budget irlandais est tel que quand la je
plus c'est un tribunal où la Commission
européenne a essayé de de remettre en
cause les rescrits fiscaux très
avantageux qu'offre l'Irlande de manière
organisée he donc un rescrit fiscal
c'est pas une loi un rescit fiscal il
essay ça au Luxembourg aussi avec Junker
qui avait qui avait par ailleurs présidé
la Commission européenne c'est là on
voit le l'un indépendance de la
Commission européenne, c'est l'État, un
gouvernement qui fait un accord rescrit,
un accord fiscal particulier avec une
puissance financière ou une
multinationale. Euh donc euh l'État le
le le qui est censé être une démocratie
enf démocratie irlandaise, le
gouvernement irlandais a pris le parti
des multinationales
contre euh l'intérêt européen. Non mais
donc là vous avez une agérence
monstrueuse
qui en parle. Franchement c'est c'est
enfin il y a des gens qui en parlent.
C'est c'est pas caché mais il faut
vraiment aller chercher l'info.
Quel avis vous portez sur le journalisme
français avec les deux trois petites
choses qui se sont passé depuis ces
derniers jours ?
C'est c'est très différent parce que en
fait si vous voulez
qui font encore leur boulot.
Oui. Il y en a beaucoup.
Est-ce qu'il y a une militarisation du
journalisme pour Est-ce qu'il y a une
militarisation du journalisme français
pour faire élire monsieur machin Pierre
Paul Jacques ? Non mais vous savez moi
coule Pierre Paul ou Jacques
peut-être il y a des il y a toujours il
y a peut-être des arrangements on en
voit un là mais c'est surtout il y a un
appauvrissement je vous dire la vraie
réalité c'est
cit légitime de les filmer dans un bar
mais
enfin c'est légitime je sais pas mais
comme eux l'ont fait pour d'autres c'est
bien fait pour eux il y a un moment soit
on a des principes so pas vous réjouir
de de leur malheur
ouais malheur c'est bon ils sont pas
morts il faut remettre les choses mais
je dirais mais c'est
ils en auront un autre vous il y a
tellement ils se sont tellement ces gens
se sont tellement déch enchaîner contre
d'autres. Moi, il y a un moment, j'ai
dit je suis pas un sein. Voilà, donc
voilà, je ne fais pas semblant d'être un
sain. Donc je ne souhaite pas la tête
soit un pic. J'aime pas qu'on mette les
noms en pâure, mais je vais pas non plus
nicher sur des gens qui ont mis leur
d'autres collègues pour bien moins grave
en place publique ou qui demandent la
fermeture entière de chaîne ou de médias
parce qu'il ils pensent pas comme eux.
Bon, donc faut pas non plus exagérer.
J'ai pas non plus euh euh
faire le grand pardon et machin. Faut
pas exagérer. Donc il se démerde. Mais
ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que le
vrai problème c'est ça. Mais c'est
surtout l'appauvrissement en fait du
journalisme français euh général.
C'estàd que vous avez des gens de bonne
foi. Moi je vois la presse locale qui
essaie un peu de couvrir l'actualité
locale, les communes, la politique
locale, que les gens soient informés,
ils ont pas un rond, ils sont payés au
lance-pierre dans les rédactions. Enfin,
pareil, il y aura une étude à faire,
j'ai pas le temps. Mais je pense entre
le salaire minimum vraiment, je pense
que les médias français, je pense que ça
va être une des lieux où il y a la plus
grande dispersion, vous enlevez les
milliardaires évidemment, mais de gens
qui ont un contrat qui sont salariés. la
plus grande dispersion entre le salaire
de base du pigis machin qui dépanne ou
du caméraman qui est en intermittent du
spectacle euh et du chef de rédaction
qui a 15000 par mois quoi. Vraiment là
il y a une dispersion énorme. C'est
quand même ce qui fait il y a vraiment
un loup penolétariat de la presse qui
essaie de faire son boulot des gens qui
résistent et puis vous avez des
idéoccrates.
Mais je veux dire, c'est pas forcément
qu'ils sont une fois plus on en revient
exactement à ce que je disais au début
de l'entretien. C'est des gens qui sont
dans leur propre réalité et donc moi
pour être beaucoup en débat avec eux,
ils sont rarement de mauvaise foi dans
leur monde parallèle. Ils sont
sincèrement et pleinement les pieds dans
un monde qui n'est pas la la le monde
d'une majorité. C'est un monde mais
c'est un monde d'un tout petit monde et
c'est pas le monde de la majorité.
On a vu que Marine Le Pen avait été
condamné à une peine d'ingigibilité
pour des montages financiers de je tire
du pognon à gauche pour rétribuer les
emplois fictifs et en C'est quoi votre
avis là-dessus ? Tous les partis
politiques font ça ou il y a que le
frein national ?
Ah non mais je pense que là c'est un une
machination de toute pièce. Je pense que
ce dossier et parce que ce dossier est
faux de la jusqu'à Z. C'est-à-dire que
elle a été condamnée ou pas ?
Mais elle a été condamnée. Oui mais sur
des pièces qui n'ont rien à voir. Vous
savez la faire Alstom. Vous savez que
comment a commencé la destruction
d'Alstom ? C'est-à-dire que c'est un
juge d'instruction qui a mis en examen
du jour au lendemain le PDG de la CGE
pour soitant des travaux illégaux dans
son bureau. Donc il a été interdit de
diriger la CGE. Son successeur a
démantelé donc Alcatel d'un côté, Alstom
de l'autre et ça c'est fini comme on a
fini. Et puis en fait 10 ans plus tard
ou 20 ans plus tard, il est toujours
vivant, je crois d'ailleurs le le le PDG
de de l'époque, il a écrit ça sur
internet, tout le monde peut le
retrouver. euh 10 ans plus tard, il a eu
un non lieu. Bon bah sur le moment, vous
aurez dit "Ah oui mais vous tu es mis en
examen, il doit bien il y a pas de fumer
sans feu." Voilà. Bon euh donc euh tout
il en a d'autres qui ont été condamné
non
de quoi
sur les emplois fictifs.
Ah mais là c'est les du Parlement
européen. Non mais tout ça mais même
pour monsieur Berérou d'ailleurs moi
j'ai toujours dit depuis le début je dis
la même chose. Faut se remettre dans le
contexte. À l'époque où cette affaire
né, ce sont les trois opposants internes
à l'Union européenne qui sont mis en
cause. Le modè à l'époque, ça paraît
dingue aujourd'hui puisqu'il est avec
Macron, mais à l'époque François Berou
est un opposant du régime. Il critique
Big sur TF1, il critique la corruption
interne de l'Union européenne, hop, il
est mis en cause. Euh RA nationale
évidemment critique de l'Union
européenne et les insoumis qui sont la
force de gauche critique de l'Union
européenne. Donc comme par hasard, les
trois mis en cause dans cette affaire
sont les trois forces critiques de
l'interne de l'Union européenne. Donc
moi, je ne serai pas dû sur ce qui s'est
passé. L'affaire a commencé, j'étais pas
assemblée nationale, j'étais encore avec
monsieur Dupignan et depuis le début et
Dupignant lui-même l'a dit, c'est une
affaire de de cornecul qui vise et qui à
mon avis a perdu le contrôle de ceux qui
l'ont voulu l'amener et qui a mis nos
institutions dans une situation
extrêmement grave qui vise à enf plus à
force de vouloir décrédibiliser sur le
long cours les forces d'opposition qui
menacent notre démocratie et la capacité
à présenter Marine Le Pen principal
force d'opposition. Voilà. Et
d'ailleurs, moi je le dis he, les
insoumis et toutes ces forces de gauche
contestataires qui se rendent pas compte
qu'ils ont nourri le monstre qui les
dévorera aussi et bah rigolera. Enfin,
c'est pas drôle mais je pense qu'à la
fin c'est il rigoler pas non plus.
Question internet, un petit mot sur le
Bitcoin.
Écoutez, moi fondamentalement je je ne
peux être qu'opposé au Bitcoin puisque
pour moi la le fait alors vous allez me
dire c'est pas le cas avec
l'indépendance des banques centrales,
c'est vrai. Mais que la monnaie soit un
outil souverain et dans les mains du
peuple pour moi est un fondement de la
démocratie. Donc si vous avez une
privatisation sous quelque forme que ce
soit euh du privilège de la monnaie,
pour moi, vous affaiblissez la
démocratie. Je comprends les tenants
aboutissants qui ont mené à la création
du Bitcoin. Je comprends que des gens
croient dans ce projet, y compris
idéologiquement et philosophiquement.
Mais je pour moi il nourrissent un
monstre qui affaiblira la démocratie.
Question internet que je découvre avec
vous. Bonjour. Alors je ne sais pas si
c'est réellement une question correcte.
Mais pourquoi c'est Bardella qui est mis
en avant au RN alors que son parcours
est quand même léger en comp en
comparaison de monsieur Tangi qui
démontre une réelle intelligence et la
capacité à choisir les batailles dans
lequelles il va s'engager pour gagner.
Pour l'interrogation.
Un petit commentaire juste derrière,
c'est absolument pas une revendication,
c'est une réelle interrogation et je ne
suis pas fan des deux personnages, je
précise
Jordan est président du parti. Il a été
élu par les militants et les meilleurs.
C'est un surdoué. Il a gagné deux
élections européennes dont une où il a
mis à plat de couture la Macronie. Un
surdoué en terme de quoi ? Bah
une capacité de conviction,
d'entraînement, de charisme, de de Non
mais surdoué, c'està dire en terme de
cuit, en terme de quoi ? bah de tout de
d'art politique, de maîtrise de l'art
politique, de maîtrise euh de de soi, de
de conviction des gens, d'entraînement,
de toutes les forces qui font la
politique également. Enfin, c'est c'est
un peu paradoxal de croire que euh pour
être à la tête d'une force politique,
faudra avoir des diplômes ou je ne sais
quoi. Si avoir des des des diplômes
quels qu'ils soi euh était gage de de
compétences et de maîtrise du dossier
politique, bah la France est très bien
géré puisqu'on a été géré que par des
gens surdiplômés avec tout ce qu'il faut
comme tampon. Donc euh euh Jordan
Bardella, il a démontré ses ses
qualités. Bon, moi je comprends pas trop
ce procès qui lui est fait.
Je vais prendre une question. Je
excusez-moi, je je vais choisir parce
qu' je je en choisir une qui a été fait
qui a été remontée par la communauté.
Laissez-moi juste une petite seconde.
Ils font des blagues. Combien de zéos à
un milliard ? Bah
9.
Bien joué.
Ouais, ça va. Je suis littéraire mais
quand même. Moi, je suis rentré à l'ess
avec l'option latin. Donc attention,
faut pas trop me chercher sur les
chiffres parce que vous allez pas me
trouver.
C'est vrai. Et vous parlez toujours
latin ?
Non, j'ai tout oublié.
C'est vrai.
C'est horrible.
Vous gardez même pas
Bah si, je quand je parlais quand
j'entends l'italien, j'arrive à peu près
à comprendre. Enfin, c'est c'est très
très loin. C'est très très loin. Vous
saz la la le problème aussi de la
politique, il faut être honnête, c'est
que ça rend un peu con.
Question internet mais qu'on a déjà un
peu abordé. Pense-t-il que pense-t-il
que Finch dégradera la notation de la
France vendredi, notamment au cas de
vote de défiance cet après-midi pour
l'interrogation ? A-t-il conscience des
conséquences d'une perte d'un double A ?
On a déjà on l'a déjà abordé.
Allez, une petite dernière.
Ah !
Est-ce que vous avez un avis sur Pierre
Eddouard Sterrain et du projet Péicles ?
Moi je l'ai dit hein, je veux dire moi
la personne de monsieur Sterrain, il a
sans doute beaucoup de qualité mais moi
je considère que si on est un vrai
patriote, on ne s'exile pas fiscalement.
Voilà, on combat de l'intérieur, on
combat voilà, on peut s'exiler, on peut
être un patriote et s'exiler si son pays
est occupé, si son pays est une
dictature, si bref vous n'avez pas les
moyens de de combattre de l'intérieur
pour défendre les valeurs que vous
voulez. Mais
c'est l'ingérance ou pas ?
Comment
c'est de l'ingérance ? Non, parce que
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a
grand-chose, hein. C'est beaucoup de
D'ailleurs, si vous voulez, le le Je
pense que le le la réalité de
l'influence de monsieur Sterrain sur le
monde politique est inversément
proportionnel au bavardage de la presse
de gauche dessus. Donc le fait que la
gauche est vu monsieur Sterrain comme le
nouvel ennemi à battre, je crois qu'
j'ai été interrogé en tout cas par deux
reportages du service public donc
financé avec notre argent public sur ce
terrain. Je je vois pas je suis pas sûr
que monsieur ce terrain pour les
électeurs français mérite qu'on lui
fasse de reportages payés par la
fonction publique. Donc en fait ce
terrain c'est en train de devenir le
nouveau diable d'une certaine gauche.
Voilà catholique pratiquant existe
épouvantail
bah pour le diable pour moi un
épouvantail.
Donc très réactionnaire sur les
questions de société, enfin il a le
droit de l'être mais complètement
marginal en fait par rapport à la
société française. Donc ça devient un
peu l'épouventail parfait pour la gauche
et l'extrême gauche. Au lieu de débattre
de fond, moi je préférais qu'on débat du
statut de l'Irlande ou de la
souveraineté économique avec la gauche.
On débat que de conneries pendant les
élections. C'est un peu triste.
Bon là là l'économie russe est bientôt à
genou. Comment on fait pour la mettre 10
ans quand même ?
Comment
ça fait 10 ans que c'est bientôt mais
comment on fait pour la mettre à ple
ventre ?
Mais je vais vous dire, moi j'aimerais
qu'on ait pu gagner que qu'on ait pu
comment dire gagner cette guerre. Enfin,
on n'est pas en guerre directement avec
la Russie mais qu'on ait pu aider les
craines en mettant à terre l'économie
russe. Si ça avait fonctionné, jeaurais
dit qu'il fallait le faire et Marine Le
Pen aurait dit qu' on aurait dit
collectivement qu'il fallait le faire.
Vous pouvez retrouver des interventions
au parlement très tôt où j'explique que
la plupart des sanctions économiques
vont renforcer le régime russe et où lui
ouvrir vers la Chine et l'Inde. Enfin,
moi je vous savez, je suis un peu
basique, il était littéraire, donc moi
je suis géographe et historien dans ma
formation. C'est ça vraiment mes deux
passions. Bon, vous prenez une carte.
Donc comme on a eu l'Allemagne deux
fois, comment on a battu l'Allemagne
deux fois, ils nous ont eu une fois euh
par la vitesse, on a pas eu le temps de
les étouffer. Comment on les a eu deux
fois ? essentiellement aussi en les
étouffant économiquement parce que vous
prenez une carte, bah vous voyez que
l'Allemagne n'a pas accès au grand large
ni au continent asiatique ni Afrique.
Donc l'Afrique à Corp d'ailleurs donc
c'est compliqué euh c'est compliqué sur
la durée de de tenir face au aux
affronts entre autres problèmes. Bon bah
la Russie, vous regardez une carte, bah
elle est ouverte sur elle est ouverte
sur les deux plus grandes puissances
démographiques du monde. Puis cette
puissance démographique et aussi toute
l'Asie du Sud-Est parce qu'on parle
toujours de la Chine mais il y a pas que
la Chine toute l'Asie du Sud-Est et
cette puissance économique,
démographique, militaire, scientifique
grandissante qui a un besoin de
ressources quasiment infini. Et donc les
sanctions ne font que offrir à Ville
Prix à l'Inde, à la Chine et à d'autres
les ressources multiples de la Russie.
Et alors si on avait réussi par un
esprit de vitesse un peu à les
contraindes, ça aurait peut-être pu
marcher. Mais bon là voilà, maintenant
ils vont faire leur gaz auoduc. le le
nouveau gazoduc et donc bah la Chine et
la Russie vont être liés par des
intérêts énergétiques qui nous
dépassent. Bon, le paradoxe et que je
pense que la Russie c'était en tout cas
le projet de Jirak essentiellement à la
base aurait plutôt voulu équilibrer ne
pas être dans la main essentiellement de
la Chine. Donc bon, après c'est pas nous
qui avons forcé la Russie à attaquer la
Ukraine évidemment, ce qui est une
attaque illégale et illégitime et
meurtrière. Mais en tout cas, les
sanctions économiques n'ont pas marché.
Mais une fois plus, moi j'aurais adoré
vraiment qu'on se trompe sur ça. Moi, si
vraiment les faits m'avaient donné tort
et nous avaient donné tort sur
l'efficacité des sanctions énergétiques
sur le régime russe, je me j'aurais été
heureux puisque ça voulait dire autant
de matériel militaire financé en moins
pour tuer des innocents en Ukraine. Euh
et puis envoyer aussi à la baston des
des des Russes, on s'en doute pas tous
demander ça. Bon, j'aurais préféré avoir
tort mais si on le dit, c'est pas Et en
plus le paradoxe si vous voulez qu'on
nous accuse des agents russes, c'est que
si on avait appliqué les sanctions que
Marine Le Pen avait recommandé pendant
la campagne impress 2022, et bien
c'était quoi comme sanction ?
La sanction c'était faire effondrer le
marché
de pétrole
de pétrole et de gaz. C'est-à-dire si
vous vouliez à court terme, comment
dire, ruiner le régime russe, il fallait
évidemment avec les États-Unis, l'OPEP,
s'entendre pour ou en tout cas et pour
le gaz encore plus puisque le client
essentiel de l'époque de la Russie avant
qu'il se retourne, c'était l'Europe.
Effondrer le marché.
À partir de combien les le budget russe
se casse cabinette ? Ça doit être 40
dollars le baril ou quelque chose comme
ça.
En dessous de 49. Ouais.
Ouais.
Euh le gaz, il faut vraiment le faire.
Il fondrait très bas et si vous voulez.
Donc en plus grand 1 euh ça aurait fait
effectivement là un problème de de dev
de devise pour le régime russe mais en
plus ça nous aurait bénéficié puisque on
aurait eu de l'énergie pas chère ce que
font les Indiens par exemple
aujourd'hui. Bon donc en fait c'est et
donc on aurait pu et on avait dit en
plus avec Marine Le Pen avait dit les
bénéfices c'estàdire il s'agissait pas
d'encaisser le bénéfice de la différence
pour nous mais on aurait pu refiler pour
le coup ce bénéfice aux Ukrainiens. Donc
tout ça était hallucinant. Ça n'a jamais
été débattu hein. C'est que la première
la principale opposante à Emmanuel
Macron à la principale élection à la
présidentielle
propose des contresanctions
redoutablement efficaces contre le
régime russe et on nous dit c'est vous
les Russes on est vraiment et on ne
débat même pas de ce qu'on a d'ailleurs
vous-même de bonne fois je pense que
vous étiez même pas au courant de ce
qu'on avait proposé à l'époque.
On a suivi ça on a
mais voilà c'est c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable ce renversement accusatoire
et vous avez des gens de bonne foi qui
pensent qu'on a rien proposé contre les
Russes. Bon donc et maintenant c'est
trop tard d'avoir fait ça. Mais pourquoi
on l'a pas fait ? C'est que ces gens
veulent faire la guerre en respectant
les règles mondialistes du marché. Donc
il faut faire la guerre à la Russie mais
il faut pas déranger les puissances de
l'argent. Donc il faut surtout pas
intervenir sur le marché du pétrole, le
marché du gaz, le marché des métaux, le
marché les marchés alimentaires. Pareil
qui a utilisé l'arme du prix des
aliments, la dépendance de l'Afrique aux
apport aux exportations euh
russaux-européennes de de blé et
d'autres bien vitaux. C'est la Russie
qu'on a profité et pas nous. Enfin,
profiter au sens utiliser cette arme euh
contre nos intérêts. Donc on est on a
été mais vraiment dans un renversement
accusatoire hallucinant
et et l'Europe qui potentiellement
peut-être puissante se castre elle-même.
C'est-à-dire que vraiment moi je je
pensais pendant le temps qu'on était des
pigeons mais en fait on est des chapons
quoi. C'estd on est de la volaille
castrée
et content de l'être pour certains.
Le chapon il fait cocorico comment ? Bah
je crois pas qu'il fasse Cocorico. Je
sais pas quel bruit il fait le chapeau
mais ça doit
une petite crête ou une grosse crête le
chapon
je sais pas je n'ai mangé que tout cuit.
Je suis désolé, j'en ai jamais j'en ai
jamais zigouillen moi-même.
Vous avez jamais fait un abattage rituel
de chapon ?
Jamais.
Bon
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire nous avec tout
ça ? On a vu notre président de la
République Emmanuel Macron lumineux et
et notre chef d'état, chef des armée,
vouloir envoyer des des volontaires
avec 28 autres pays européens en
Ukraine. C'est une bonne idée ça ?
Si euh c'est paré par l'ONU en fait ça
devient bénir à partir du moment où il y
a un pas un traité enfin un traité de
paix ou un cess c'est le feu toute forme
d'accord qui permett à cette force
d'être une force de paix et pas une épée
de damoclè nouvelle guerre
genre une force d'interposition avec des
casques bleus qui soient d'ailleurs
indien d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs mieux
ce serait d'ailleurs mieux que cette
force d'interposition ne soit pas pris à
partie du conflit directement
indirectement c'est pour ça parle que
l'Inde au cours des 50 dernières années
ou le Népal ou voilà de pays a toujours
été un fournisseur entre guillemets,
c'est pas très élégant mais de casque
bleu parce que souvent ils sont ils
avaient pas mal à partir dans dans c
dans ces conflit. Bon donc mais on peut
imaginer bon la France le fait je crois
qu'au Liban c'est c'est sous un mandat
de l'ONU de mémoire mais c'est pas ma
spécialité
exerce des forces d'interposition ça
peut se faire mais ça peut être que dans
le cadre évidemment d'un traité
extrêmement strict parce que ça ne
devrait pas devenir un nouveau levier ou
risque de nouvelles guerre d'une
deuxième guerre qui serait cette fois
une guerre non pas de la Russie sur
l'Ukraine mais entre les nations
occidentales je déteste ce mot les
nations d'Europe et la Russie façon ça
n'aura pas lieu s'il y a pas traité de
paix tout ça c'est aussi très théoriqu
Ça nous emmène où ?
Je ne sais pas où ça nous emmène. Vous
savez, moi je n'ai pas de boule de
cristal euh
et je ne suis pas malheureusement.
Vous avez déjà étudié l'histoire et la
géographie ? Oui, c'est pour ça que dès
2014, on en a parlé tout à l'heure, euh
pour le coup, j'ai monsieur DPignon et
Marine Le Pen avaient à peu près la même
analyse euh sur la finalité
malheureusement de là où ça nous
amènerait euh de pas prendre les bonnes
mesures euh en interne domestique, hein,
sur la souveraineté économique militaire
et euh et et sur la Russie. Voilà. Bon,
tout ça, enfin en fait ce qui est un peu
traclique avec les souverainistes, c'est
que c'est pour
comique.
Comment
les comiques ?
Pourquoi les comiques ? comique.
Oui, pardon. Ou tr comique. Oui oui tout
à fait. Mais c'est c'est avec les
souverainistes si vous voulez c'est que
et parfois on est un peu piégé
là-dedans. C'est qu'on a un peu
l'impression d'être des pitis quoi. Un
peu d'être cassandre d'annoncer toujours
que trois va tomber sous sa propre
traîrice et naïveté.
Mais le cheval rentre, c'estàdire voilà
donc on est cassendre les portes ont été
ouver on a vu le cheval arriver, on a vu
les portes s'ouvrir, on a vu les portes
se refermer, on voit la nuit tomber, on
sait que dans le cheval de 3, il y a des
gens qui vont nous qui vont nous
trancher la gorge, personne nous écoute
et on nous fait passer pour des fous.
C'est un peu la tragédie des
souverainistes et c'est aussi d'ailleurs
la tragédie Mélenchon quand il était
souverainiste. Il avait un peu les mêmes
analyses sur ça, sur les grands enjeux.
Ça arrivait qu'on soit d'accord soit
d'accord avec nous.
Ça fait plus de 2h et dem qu'on est en
interview. On n pas mangé et commencé à
avoir la dalle. Même s'il y a énormément
de questions, je voudrais je voudrais
que vous nous conseilliez trois livres
pour la communauté, des livres qui ont
été importants pour vous. Alors, vous
pouvez nous parler de Napoléon si vous
voulez. Non non parce que c'est pas
vrai. J'ai rien j'ai lu un peu enfin
c'est même pas l'impoléon lacass mais
c'est moi je le livre plus important
pour moi c'est les mémoires d'Adrien de
Yursenard. Ça c'est un livre que je lis
presque tous les ans.
Après je suis désolé c'est un peu
caricatural mais c'est vrai je m'en
fiche. le prince de Macavel que pareil
pour moi fondamental et désolé encore
c'est pas très original mais les
mémoires les deux mémoires enfin les
deux les
général
tous les tomes pas seulement mémoire de
guerre ou mémoire d'espoir l'ensemble
euh du général
qui euh évidemment lu avec le bagage
faut aussi avoir essayer de lire des
historiens qui vous permettent de
recontextualiser ce que de go écrit
parce qu'il écrit aussi dans un contexte
où il veut reprendre le pouvoir ou alors
il
il veut l'exercer encore ou il a pas eu
le temps de finir le mémoire d'espoir.
Voilà, il faut aussi recontextualiser
mais c'est surtout en fait c'est pas
tant en fait ce qui est intéressant dans
les mémoire de de Gaulle, c'est pas tant
les événements qu'il racontent où il y a
des historiens qui sont meilleurs que
lui qui ont plus d'archives depuis mais
c'est toute sa philosophie de la façon
dont il voit les choses. Vous avez parlé
de sa reconnaissance de la Chine ce
qu'il dit sur les les comment dire les
les identités les permanences des
civilisations. Voilà, si Degol était là
aujourd'hui, je pense qu'il aurait
jamais laissé l'Allemagne refaire son
unité dans ses conditions et qu'il
n'applaudit pas quand l'Allemagne
annonce son réarmurement.
Est-ce que l'Allemagne en sortant de la
guerre avait promis qu'elle se
réarmerait pas ? Qu'elle
qu'elle avait promis qu'elle sera enfin
c'est pas qu'elle a promis, c'est qu'on
la contrainte à pas se réar
et qu'elle elle ne toucherait jamais au
l'arme nucléaire de près ou de loin.
Est-ce qu'il y a des accords comme ça ?
Non. Vous pouvez rappeler, il y a eu
plusieurs accords enf déjà déjà il y a
les accords je sais pas si c'est à Post
Dame enfin il y a l'ensemble des accords
de de dire de règlement de la guerre
elle-même enf a des déplacements de
population allemande avec aussi une
reconcentration des populations
allemandes sur l'espace qui leur a été
définitivement je l'espère attribué le
le le le et l'Allemagne. Après vous avez
la guerre froide qui fait que la RFA
finalement se réarme partiellement, se
réintègre dans l'OTAN. Mais le général
de pareil, voyez par exemple, on dit le
traité de ou traité de l'Élysée entre
Dan c'est Élysée entre Daner et et de
Gaulle. Bref,
ce traité qui était défié après il était
d'autant plus déifié qu'il n'est plus le
traité que voulait le général de Gaulle.
puisque le traité que veut le général de
Gaulle, effectivement un couple
franco-allemand à l'époque, peut-être
que ça aurait du sens plus après où
l'Allemagne se détache en la RFA se
détache de son patronnage américain et
puis finalement le Parlement allemand
euh change l'accord et vous avez les
représentants américains et les agents
d'influence américain qui sont à
l'époque dans les través du parlement
euh de RFA et qui applaudissent quand
euh quand comment dire le le traité de
l' enfin Le traité entre la France et
l'Allemagne n'est plus le traité de De
Gaulle, mais le traité revisité par
l'OTAN. Voilà. Bon, et en fait depuis ça
n'a pas changé. Voilà. Bon, donc on est
très loin même là-dedans, on est très
très loin. Comment dire du ce que
j'appelle le moulin à prière quoi. Vous
savez, c'est ce moulin à prière, c'est
en Asie.
tibétain, vous passez à côté et puis
pour pas faire la vous agitez le moulin
et puis vous avez fait vos bonnes
actions.
Une fois, j'ai failli ouvrir, j'avais
failli avant qu'il démissionne pour
l'anecdote, j'avais commandé un moulin
prière pour Bruder le maire avant qu'il
démissionne enfin avant qu'il soit
démissionné. J'en ai j'en pouvais plus
de l'entendre en commission d'enquête en
commission finances et donc je voulais à
force de lui dire vous avez été moulin à
prière, j'ai vraiment failli lui ramener
un moulin prière que j'avais
le moulin prière portable.
Oui, le petit portable avec le le petit
Oui, oui, oui, voilà, exactement. J'ai
failli lui amener le boulin prière à
J'ai pas eu le temps à
C'est quoi comme prière dessus ?
J'en sais rien. J'ai acheté le premier
venu complètement. C'est juste pour la
pour la blague.
C'est blasphématoire.
C'est un peu blasphématoire pour ceux
qui croient pour les bouddhistes. Je le
reconnais. C'est un peu le c'est un peu
irrespectueux, c'est vrai. Mais bon, moi
je moi je suis l'école Charbdo. Moi
Charles ça me fait rire. Voilà.
Est-ce qu'on peut blasphémer encore en
France ?
Pour le moment oui mais ils ont presque
gagné. C'està dire qu'on voit même dans
la presque en public, il y a presque
plus de caricature. Ah oui oui l'hommage
à Charlie Hebdo. Charlie pour tout
Forever machin toujours Charlie tu
parles. Il y a plus grandchose de
Charlie dans la presse française hein.
Et encore mais ceci dit fier d'être
français sans mauvais sans cynisme parce
qu'on est les derniers qui résistent
ailleurs c'est fini. Y compris
d'ailleurs dans des démocraties qu'on
même pas d'islamistes dans leur sein
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique qui pourrai
très bien continuer à être enfin bon les
protestants anglo-saxons étaient pas
spécialementérencieux. Enfin, s'il avait
voulu l'être, ils auraient pu l'être. Ça
enfin, vous voyez la presse même new
yorkaaise, tout ça, c'est devenu
vraiment euh vraiment des des des lèche
bottes des des fanatiques.
Question internet. Pensez-vous qu'il est
indispensable d'avoir des enfants pour
gouverner ? Peut-on croire en l'avenir
sans enfant ?
Oui, moi je je n pas d'enfant. Il y a
peu de
Vous az adopté ?
Non, enfin je crois pas. Mais
vous avez un chat ?
Non.
J'essaie de me gérer moi-même.
Vous vivez chez maman ?
Non, pas du tout. Je suis parti pour le
coup Tangy n'est pas du tout adapté
parce que moi je suis parti à 17 ans. On
est une famille très autonome. Non non,
c'est pas du tout adapté. Mais non, mais
j'espère que j'aurai des enfants. Je
sais pas si j'en aurai mais mais je
trouve c'est un peu c'est un peu bas
comme remarque quoi. Le réarmement
démographique sans crèche, sans sans
pédiatre, sans service de santé, sans
sans sans école, sans prof bien payé.
Mais
ça n'existe pas. De toute façon, on voit
bien que toutes les politiques entre
guillemets de de favor favorisant la
démographie qui repose sur des chèqus
échouent. le
le favoriser la démographie, c'est vous
voyz c'est un système, c'est une
confiance, il faut que les gens se
disent je peux c'est pas que une
histoire d'argent. Enfin, moi qui n'ai
pas d'enfant, le le ma condition
financière n'a jamais joué dans la
possibilité ou pas d'avoir un enfant et
mes amis, mes proches, ma famille qui se
questionne sur avoir des enfants, c'est
jamais une question d'avoir des enfants.
Pour moi, il y a ça. Et il y a aussi
pour moi la première peut-être un peu
surprendre ceux qui nous écoutent, mais
pour moi, la première des critères dans
une démocratie moderne, dans une société
post-industrielle de favoriser la
natalité, c'est la liberté des femmes.
S'il y a pas de liberté absolue des
femmes, absolue la plus grande possible,
si les femmes n'ont pas la certitude de
pouvoir vivre comme elles le souhaitent,
de pouvoir réaliser leurs rêves à au
moment de la vie où elles ont ces rêves
là, de faire
même salaire,
même salaire, même effort, d'avoir un
peu d'aide de la société sur la charge
mentale. Voilà, c'est pas voyez, c'est
du gauchisme, enfin n'importe quoi.
C'est c'est pas du tout du gauchisme.
C'est c'est faire un beau cadeau à ceux
qui pensent avoir le monopole du droit
des femmes de dire non, c'est essentiel.
Et d'ailleurs, pourquoi les États-Unis
arrivent à maintenir aussi un taux de
totalité élevé ? C'est que il y a une
forme de féminisme aux États-Unis très
fort quoi. Voilà, vous êtes une femme,
si vous voulez faire carrière aux
États-Unis, vous la faites. Pourquoi le
Royaume-Uni a tenu ? C'était aussi des
zones assez égalitaristes entre les
hommes et les femmes. Pourquoi même
malgré tous leurs efforts, pourquoi le
Japon, la Corée, l'Allemagne, la
Pologne, la Hongrie, des pays que tout à
fait de respect pour ces pays n'arrivent
pas à relancer leur natalité même quand
ils mettent du fric ? que le statut des
femmes dans ces pays, c'est pas possible
quoi. Pas le statut légal,
le statut de la Moi j'ai vécu au Japon
au secours quoi. Enfin, j'adore vraiment
j'ai plus grand respect pour le Japon,
pour sa civilisation, pour sa culture.
Mais le statut de la femme au Japon,
c'est la cause de la pour moi c'est la
cause de l'effondrement de de la
démographie.
La soumission de la femme.
C'est pas une soumission, c'est qu'elles
n'ont pas le droit de vivre la vie
qu'elle rêve. Pas le droit. Également,
elles ont le droit. Il a vécu combien de
temps au Japon ?
Une petite année, ça m'a suffi. Moi,
j'ai assisté à des scènes, j'ai
travaillé pour Itachi dans une très
grande multinationale japonaise. J'ai
assister à des scènes inimaginables en
France où on voit que la femme la femme
comme représentation sociale et
sociétale n'a pas le droit de citer
avec des mecs qui sont là à proposer à
une ingénieur, une femme brillante de
dire "Non non mais je t'adore, tu as
fait une belle carrière mais maintenant
tu vas rester à la maison."
à ta place quoi. Et oui et en plus ce
qui est paradoxal au Japon avec les
femmes ont une représentation
culturelle, il y a eu des imp il y a eu
des femmes impératrices. Enfin pour moi
ça n enfin une fois de plus, moi j'ai
j'ai pas de leçons à donner à aucune
civilisation mais moi quand mes amis
japonais me disent bah pourquoi ? Parce
qu'à l'époque on avait un beau tau de
natalité donc j'avais beaucoup de
Japonais qui me demandaient comment vous
faites en France ? Bah je leur avais dit
mais la France le statut de la femme en
France c'est la première garantie
d'un taux de natalité élevé. Voilà. Et
d'ailleurs, je pense aussi que
l'effondrement en France est lié à
l'effondrement d'un certain nombre de
droits féminin, pas dans la loi mais
dans la société, au quotidien, dans la
rue,
genre pas pouvoir s'habiller comme vous
voulez, ne pas pouvoir vivre comme vous
voulez, pas pouvoir vous amuser. Donc
tout ça exerce une force psychologique
nocive sur les femmes quelle qu'elle
soit. Voilà. Mais même des femmes qui
sont conservatrices, s'agit pas. Oui, la
liberté des femmes c'est se mettre en
mini jupe. La liberté des femmes n'est
pas de se mettre en mini jupe en soi. La
liberté des femmes est de faire ce
qu'elles veulent.
par les japonais,
j'ai tout oublié aussi.
Comment on dit mourir de travail ?
Je sais pas. En plus, c'est une formule.
En plus, c'est une expression parce
queil y a des il y a un phénomène de
mort au travail au Japon. Donc en plus,
c'est une expression dans l'expression.
Mais j'ai oublié.
Je dois pas avoir la bonne
prononciation.
C'est le japonais se prononce on n pas
de problème de prononciation en entre un
français et un japonais.
Karaoshi.
Oui, c'est si c'est bien prononcé.
Enfin, je sais pas si ça veut dire ça
mais il y a une expression. C'est comme
ceux qui sont enfermés dans leur maison,
dans leur chambre avec internet. Il y a
plusieurs concepts comme ça au Japon de
langue dans la langue. J'ai tout oublié.
Est-ce que vous avez un un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose d'impérissable. On
avait tellement de questions à vous
poser, donc il va falloir revenir.
Non ben je reviendrai. Non mais les
humanités voilà moi seul conseil que
j'ai à dire au à ceux qui nous écoutent
maintenant que je suis plus tout jeune,
la seule chose qui m'est utile au
quotidien. Ah si si en si. Non mais je
rigole. La seule chose qui m'est utile,
voyez, moi aussi je suis victime de la
société contemporaine américaine. La
seule chose qui m'est utile vraiment
fondamentalement, il y a des choses que
j'ai oublié à par les japonais, les
choses que j'ai oublié, latin et tout,
mais pareil, j'ai oublié comment parler
latin mais j'ai pas oublié la
civilisation latine, la façon de penser,
comment on faisait une traduction, une
version aller chercher dans le
dictionnaire, la source, confronter une
traduction, une version latine, elle est
bonne. Une traduction latine du latin au
français, elle est bonne. Si vous savez
quand a écrit le texte en latin dans
quel contexte un texte de la guerre des
Gaules de entre César 1er siècle avant
Jésus-Christ ne va pas être traduit de
la même façon qu'un texte de la fin de
l'empire.
Voilà. Donc c'est tout un temp en fait
c'est pas le à chaque fois enfin
excusez-moi les imbéciles qui disent "Ah
mais ça sert à rien latin c'est une
langue morte." Bah bien sûr que c'est
une langue morte. Merci pour
l'information. Voilà mais c'est ça ça
c'est une c'est comme ceux qui sont
matteux. Moi je suis pas matteux. C'est
la mécanique, les réflexes que ça vous
donne. Ne pas vous laisser embobiner,
toujours curieux, aller chercher.
Voilà, c'estàdire faire confiance à la
fois des références parce que vous allez
chercher dans le gaffiot le le
dictionnaire de référence de traduction
euh latin français. D'un côté, vous
faites confiance aux institutions
puisque vous allez chercher dans un
livre, mais vous avez aussi la curiosité
qui remet en cause. Donc c'est un
mélange entre l'horiz entre la
verticalité du savoir et l'humilité
qu'on doit avoir
face à la transmission du savoir et un
peu de liberté d'autonomie d'aller
d'être curieux voilà de savoir pourquoi
on traduisait pourquoi il y a voilà il y
a il y a 100 ans. On disait pas que il y
avait des des tabous sur la sexualité
des Romains qui rendaient des textes un
peu chiants. Et puis maintenant, il y a
plus de tabou, donc on peut un peu plus
se marrer et profiter et rigoler un peu
plus en traduisant des textes. Voilà, la
personnage de Cléopâtre aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus sympathique qu'il était
quand la société était misogyne et
voyait qu'une sorcière horrible. Voilà.
Bon, donc voyez un mélange entre
verticalité, respect de la transmission
et
la transgression horizon entre nous.
C'est rigolo enfin moi dire il est
dingue. Moi ça m'amuse. Et Yursenard
c'est ça. Urursenard c'est vraiment la
verticalité
pression de de de vivre sous Adrien et
en même temps c'est très contemporain.
C'est vraiment un bijou ce truc ce truc
cette œuvre.
Jean-Philippe Tangy. Merci.
Merci.
[Musique]